Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Um, welcome to the launch of Snow...South Park...Snow...sorry.
South Park Snow Day!
I swear the more I stream, I guess like, my English is deteriorating.
I don't know if Sound Guy is alive today.
I hear Sound Guy will be...
Uh...oh he is!
He is alive!
Type in the YouTube chat!
I see...oh fuck!
Okay, what?
No!
I didn't mean to start!
Okay, alright, we're starting.
I had like an intro and everything planned, but like, I guess we're starting.
Isn't South Park always snowing?
Isn't that the whole thing?
Isn't it always snowing?
What?
When was there any other weather in South Park?
Yay!
People are dead!
That means school is cancelled!
Yay!
Storm is not going any further than stopping!
And with the snow piling up and roads icing...
Oh god, they're gonna cancel ski!
You see...
Did they cancel school yet?
Did they cancel ski?
Eric!
Yeah, but now...now it's different.
Now, instead...I think...I think I've heard about this.
Because now that like, we're so used to like, online learning from COVID...
Even if it's a snow day now, apparently some schools will just transition to like, online learning.
So they'll be like, school is cancelled!
That's okay!
We have online learning classes for you to go to instead!
So this doesn't matter anymore.
This was something we used to have.
Hahaha!
Back in my day, little Timmy, we had school days where we actually don't have to do schoolwork.
We didn't have good enough technology for online learning classes.
Did they cancel ski?
Remember what they took from you?
City officials are warning that even first responders will be staying home today.
The roads are completely blocked.
There is no toilet paper anywhere!
What a bad ski!
This truly feels like the end of days.
Everyone, please, take care of yourselves!
It's okay.
Those people don't matter.
They're not main characters.
Yay!
There's no ski!
No school!
That's a toilet paper!
There's no ski!
No, no, no ski!
See you later, Mom!
I'll be back in a couple hours!
Have some brunch ready for me!
Nerd!
I'm going outside to play with my friends!
I don't think that's safe, sweetie!
Mom, it's a snow day.
I feel like this is just a React channel now.
I'm watching South Park.
Which I don't mind!
Today we're just going to be watching South Park episodes on the Doki Bird channel.
Snow
key!
Oh my god!
You're in 3D!
No school, everybody!
Snow key!
No school!
Come on, brothers!
Let's go, Stan!
Snow day, everyone!
People are dying in the snow!
New kid, I'm talking to you!
That's me!
There you are!
Come on, new kid!
New kid!
That's me!
Okay, before I accidentally started the game...
Before I...
I wanted to talk about...
Usually I would have 10-15 minutes of Zazadan before I actually start the game.
But then I accidentally started the game.
So we had...
Anyway!
As I was saying...
The riskiest part about...
Um...
The riskiest part about playing a game on launch and then like not knowing if a game is good or not...
I was worried because...
Okay, like...
I love South Park.
I actually really like South Park.
I've been like keeping up to date with all the new South Park episodes.
And like I watched almost every episode of South Park.
I grew up watching South Park as well.
I shouldn't have.
But because like...
My parents didn't really know what I was watching when I was like home alone.
So then like, you know...
When my parents used to like own a restaurant...
They would leave me at home.
And then South Park would be playing.
And then I'd be watching it.
Like on TV on Comedy Central.
And I'd be like, yay!
South Park!
And I'd be like really young.
I shouldn't have been watching it.
Like I absolutely should not have been watching South Park.
Also...
I used to have like this...
One of my parents is like ex-friends.
They're not friends anymore.
But they had kids too.
So then like the older sister would like take...
Trick my parents into taking me to watch the South Park movie.
I was definitely way too young for that.
I had zero understanding of what the fuck I was watching.
And then I apparently...
My parents got really fucking mad.
When...
Because then the older sister was like...
Like my parents ex-friends like daughter was like...
No, it's an animation.
Like she can watch it.
And then...
So then she tricked my parents to like...
Because like she wanted to watch it.
So then like by doing so they're like...
Oh yeah, I'm gonna let Doki watch it with me.
So that like she's allowed to watch this movie.
Then they're like, oh, it's a kid's animated movie.
Yeah, you can totally bring little Doki over to like watch with you at the theater.
So...
Like here's the money.
Here's some money.
So you can like treat yourself and watch that movie with little Doki.
And then, you know, I got taken to watch the South Park movie.
I like remember bits of it in my head.
I haven't rewatched...
I never rewatched this movie by the way.
But I still remember it because...
Because...
Because, you know, it was like I guess like PTSD because I was way too young.
And I was way too young.
And I should not have been...
I watched like music videos of the songs from that movie recently.
But yes, I was way too fucking young to be watching the South Park movie.
But that's why I'm like this.
That's why...
That's...
That's why I'm sort of like this.
Also, also, thank you Mr. Rich.
Thank you.
Blame Canada.
Anyway.
And then...
So, I love South Park.
I 100% completed Stick of Truth.
I haven't touched the fractured but whole South Park game yet because that was like a game I really wanted to play on stream.
But I also was really worried because like I played Stick of Truth and I was like, I know that the Stick of Truth was incredibly...
I don't know if I ever want to stream Stick of Truth on stream because of how bad it is in terms of...
It's really bad.
It's so...
Like...
But I haven't spoiled anything for fractured but whole because like I don't want it because like this is like one of the rare moments where I don't want to be spoiled because like you have to be surprised.
I can't even try.
You have to go in completely blind for that game.
For the South Park games.
But the thing is, the only thing I know about the Fractured But Whole game, is the Diabetes Kid.
One of the cutscenes popped up in my recommended and I watched it.
It was so fucking stupid.
It was so good.
But it was so... that was the only thing I remember.
Super Diabetes, yes.
That was the only thing I was able to spoil myself on.
But I have not... I don't know anything that's going on in that game.
I know it's a sequel to the Stake of Truth.
But I didn't want to spoil it.
But I don't know if it's appropriate.
I don't know if it's appropriate to stream.
So...
That's why I haven't streamed it yet.
Maybe one day.
One day.
Because I know Stake of Truth is so fucked up.
Anyway, I love South Park and I keep up to date with South Park.
But the thing about how risky it is to stream games on launch...
The thing is...
Is that...
So apparently we have to turn... Let me turn down a little bit first.
Is that... The thing about it is that...
I don't know how good the game is.
And then I checked the reviews for this game and I was so sad.
Because it's mixed reviews.
I was so sad.
I was like...
No!
The reviews!
It's mixed!
Because they've hit home runs on all their... on their last two games.
I was like... No!
And then... Okay, I don't... Look.
Okay.
IGN gave it a 3.
But like... It's IGN.
So I'm like... I don't know how much I can trust IGN.
I was like... IGN has said some really weird shit about video games.
So I never really cared much about IGN reviews.
But they gave it a 3.
And I was like... No!
Why is it mixed?
I'm just like... Why?
Apparently, the issue is that this game is very expensive.
Like that is like one of the biggest issues for this game.
It's like... It's like way too expensive for how long...
It's apparently a 5 hour game max.
Or like minimum.
Oh sorry, minimum.
It's a minimum 5 hour game.
And it's like basically it's supposed to be like...
Like a hack and slash.
It's like a hack and slash.
And people were complaining.
About how...
5 hours for like a campaign and stuff.
But then they also said they're gonna add more to it.
They're gonna add...
They're gonna add more to the game later on.
But then people were like...
Whoa!
Why is it only 5 hours?
Because it's multiplayer.
There's multiplayer elements to it.
So we're gonna see ourselves.
We're gonna see ourselves.
Why this game is mixed.
We're gonna see.
By the way.
I bought the deluxe version.
So it was not just $30.
You can tell I have cred.
You can tell I paid a win.
I need people to know I paid a win.
Because I have cred right now.
Wait is cred the DLC?
I don't actually know.
I assume cred is the DLC.
So I spent...
I need...
I need people to know that I have cred.
I'm flashing that cred right here.
Alright.
Okay I should have...
Okay I...
Oh my god I can be a gnome.
Wait!
I can be a gnome?
Oh my god.
Get gnomed.
Every time you look at me you're gonna get gnomed.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Let's have...
Okay.
Alright.
Yellow.
Yellow hair.
And then...
Do they have...
No they don't.
Okay.
Let's see.
They can't...
I can't be bug?
I can't be bugged?
That's fucked up!
I can't believe I can't be bugged.
Oh I can be!
Oh nice.
Guys.
I can be.
I can be balding.
That's good enough.
That's good enough for me.
That's...
Balding is good enough you know.
It's almost like bald.
I got cred.
I need people to know I paid $50.
I...
I need people to know that I didn't wait for the reviews and I pre-ordered $50.
I pre-ordered for $50.
I need people to know that I am that shameless.
I did not read the reviews.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh I can be ginger.
Oh wait.
I could be ginger balding.
Wait!
It's not offensive because they are not real people.
I should be careful.
I should be careful what I say.
I...
Okay.
I'm going to be, I'm going to be a ginger.
They have no soul.
It's true.
If South Park says it's true, then, then it has to be.
Right?
I take my facts from, I learn about my news from South Park because they are always up to date.
Yeah, I'm going to...
Oh you're ever going to do the soullister.
Oh my God!
There is emotes?
Nice.
That's what I like to see.
Alright.
Do they actually have like... Oh my god!
They have the Snoopy dance!
This is it.
This is the real gameplay.
The dancing is the real gameplay.
Alright.
I'm done.
Finished.
That good?
What is this?
I don't know.
Clapping.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm good.
I can be Ginger.
It's 10 out of 10.
Don't worry, mom.
Who's... Who got OP?
That can't be me.
Find the keeper of the rules.
Apparently, there's like online multiplayer too.
So, WASD to walk.
Okay.
I'm using my control...
Let me... Let me use my controller!
No!
Alright, guys.
Apparently, I'm gonna be using my controller.
So... Apparently...
Alright.
I'm gonna be using mouse and keyboard like a true PC bro.
I'm gonna be... Okay.
Alright.
So, apparently, I need to turn down the music a little bit.
Sound guy.
Don't worry.
I'm turning down my music.
Let me know if everything is okay.
If I should make it louder.
Okay.
I need to remap.
Alright.
Let me turn down everything.
It's alright.
I've always... I just wanted to play on mouse and keyboard anyway.
Jesus Christ.
Why is the sensitivity so fucking high?
Okay.
I better?
I love being so fucking stickler for this.
There you go.
That's a lot better.
Hey, you two.
Come meet me on the roof.
We gotta get you up to speed.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'm coming over, butters.
Is there actually no subtitles?
Okay.
Wait.
There actually is no...
Oh, there we go.
I was like...
I forgot accessibility.
Okay.
There we go.
I was gonna be like, where the fuck is the subtitles?
I'm like, okay.
I know you don't care so far.
But damn.
You don't care about reading.
You actually don't care.
Nice.
Okay.
We have... We can read now.
We can read.
That's so nice.
Are we on Discord?
Oh my God!
We're on Discord!
Okay.
How do I get on top of the school?
There's South Park Elementary.
They understand that don't keep at...
Alright.
Here we go.
You can hide in deep snow to protect you from any projectiles.
And put you all you've been set on fire.
Stay in deep snow too long, however, will chill you with slows and deal damage.
How do I... Oh!
That's where I could hide.
Okay.
Discord is over.
The wizard says toilet paper is more precious than gold right now.
Pick some up, new kid!
Oh my God!
That's mine.
Use that toilet paper like real money.
Use it to buy a weapon.
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
Oh my God!
Toilet paper is money?
No!
I thought it was over!
Apparently, COVID is coming back.
Did you guys hear that?
It's never over.
Bro, this is...
So fucked up.
Alright.
Ooh, weapons!
Oh, Tolkien.
Not again!
It kind of never left.
We thought it left, but that was just us lying to ourselves.
Okay.
And then hold to release for maximum attack.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Bro, wake up!
It's 2020 again.
Ooh, upgrades!
Where is I?
No.
I...
I thought...
What?
Self-park!
Powers and special skills.
I forgot.
I'm the chosen one.
Powers and special skills you can use apart from your weapons.
You have gained your first power now.
But later, you can equip up to two powers at once.
Unlock new powers by completing milestones and exploring a self-park.
Alright.
Is there like...
Oh my god, I can float.
No!
Please!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck happened to the school?
Holy shit!
I love how like the school looks amazing by the way.
And then there's me.
Like this looks actually really...
I'm sorry.
But like the background looks actually really good.
I just look so...
I don't look like I blend well with the background.
This is not fit at all.
It is.
Now look kids, I know school is closed.
But you should be at home doing remote learning.
No!
Get back home and see how it is.
Not remote learning!
I can't believe it.
Kids today will never know the joy of a snow day.
No!
You see those elf kids up there?
Go get them.
Remember, humans hate elves.
No, not the...
But what if I want to be an elf?
Hello new kid, hit it.
What if I want to be an elf?
Hold on fellas.
Oh my god.
No kid doesn't know how to dodge yet.
What do you mean?
Oh yeah, I actually don't.
I never dodge.
Okay.
We gotta dodge by shift.
Okay, that seems easy.
That's alright.
They're younger than me.
Yeah, get those elves.
It's called survival of the fittest.
If you live through my slashes, you get to go to first grade.
Oh, we got you there.
Oh shit.
Oh wait, do I...
Oh, Butter's a healer!
He's like a medic!
That was great.
You totally got that one right in the face.
That was good.
What is this?
Soul Slayer?
Oh my god.
Finally a Soul Slayer game I like.
It's not actually Soul Slayer.
It's like a hack-and-slash, apparently.
Oop.
How did I miss?
I have to let go!
Okay.
Finally, the FPS portion of the game.
Okay, I definitely need to lower my sensitivity then.
Oh my god.
Look at me go.
Please.
Please stop running.
Oh, I can stop.
Okay, thank you.
I was gonna say.
I don't think I'm level up.
Wait, what is this elf doing here?
I thought we hate elves!
It's not racism.
Because they deserve-
I'm sorry.
Soap Park makes me a different person.
Get back here, elf!
Get back over here.
You're not real- You don't have rights.
You're an elf.
Oh shit!
It was a trap?
They're not human!
They don't have human rights!
And elf rights do not exist yet.
Yeah, we can tell Doki.
Alright, nice.
Plant a totem that heals you and your allies for sure.
Oh!
That's good!
Also sound- Has the sound been good so far?
Alright.
Plant a totem.
Oh, I get to heal.
Okay, E is healing.
Okay.
Yay!
Alright.
Kids can only use powers once you're pissed off!
Your pissed off meters increases by taking or dealing damage.
Using powers will decrease leadiness.
If you can't use powers, fight with your weapons until you're pissed off again.
Nice.
Is that a fucking food?
Am I just eating snacks?
Oh shit, where are the elves?
Oh shit!
Where did it come from?
How did I forget?
Okay, I need to remember guys.
Oh my god, how do I weapon swap?
How do I weapon swap?
I forgot how to weapon swap!
I already forgot!
Oh my god!
I don't want to use my bow!
Buddies!
I'll be!
Where's A?
No, that's not A!
He's moving!
Oh!
It's just left click!
Oh my god, it's just left click!
I don't have to do anything.
It was just left click.
Right click was bow and then left click was sword.
Guys, I'm learning.
I should be a game tester.
Alright, there we go.
We're good, we're good.
We can do this.
We are so good at this game.
It's okay, I can't die.
Butter is just gonna heal me forever.
Great, thank you for the Akka soup!
Thank you!
The soup is for Elves Rice.
Justice for Elves!
Thank you for the Akka soup!
If a ginger said elves have no rights, that's when you know it's serious.
Alright, nice.
I should be a game journalist, honestly.
Okay, flying daggers.
Dagger dive does 4 more damage after 0.3 seconds.
Creates a gas cloud that lingers.
Your arrow stuns distant enemies for 6 seconds and do 100% more damage?
Oh my god!
I already have a Oh, it's a legendary upgrade!
Nice.
I'm gaming.
Thank you, Jimmy.
I really appreciate it.
Now where do I go?
Wait, there's more?
Oh god.
Okay, give me a sec.
I wanna use my cool-off-ass ability.
I'm dead.
I can't believe they got actual kids to do this.
You know like for the kids voice acting?
Uh...
Like Trey gets his child to do the voice acting?
I think they get like actual staff kids.
They actually get like the staff's children to do the voice acting for the kids.
Which is like, you know...
I guess you don't have to pay them?
You just pay yourself?
At that point?
Yeah, they're actual real kids.
Yeah!
Yeah, his daughter does like some of the children voice acting.
Alright, let's get the audio in.
We gotta boost up the sound effect by 5.
And then we gotta go to the next level.
And then...
Bring down the music by 5.
Okay.
Let me know if it's okay now, Soundgath.
Okay, uncommon.
Thank god they put... I always forget the colors.
I always forget the colors for like the rarity.
So I'm so...
glad that they actually tell me.
Cause I always forget.
Alright.
Far escape deals 30% more damage and pulls enemies inwards.
Nice.
Wait, can I not buy it?
Can I pour?
Choose an upgrade?
I want this.
Oh!
Upgrade!
To get... Oh!
They're forcing me to upgrade!
What if it's good?
Nevermind, this is not good.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, they know.
Children don't fucking read.
All upgrade cards have a level each of which offers...
Yeah!
Okay.
Can upgrade rarity for a bribe!
Oh!
It's a bribe!
Nice.
Teacher says corruption.
Okay, double tapping a target with blow creates 10 damage.
6 meter blast.
Wait, that's so good.
However, to promote...
Can I promote it even more?
Ultra legendary!
Nice.
Doki plans to be an IGN game trip.
My only issue...
Is that I don't read.
Other than that...
Oh My God, he's a bigger ELF!
Why are they feeding these ELF children?
Oh my god.
I knew it.
I knew...
We shouldn't trust these ELFs.
Get off.
Get away from me.
My only issue is that I don't read.
The moment I figured out the mechanics.
I'm out of game journalism territory.
Like...
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
There's so many of them.
Okay, don't worry.
See, we got this.
But it's so smart though to getting your kids to like...
get your kids to do the voice acting because then you're technically paying yourself, you know?
You're technically just paying yourself so you don't lose money.
Whoa!
Nice, I got free labor.
Look at that.
They get bigger and louder.
So true.
Yay, TP!
Wait, how do I open up multiplayer so you guys can join us?
Wait, what's the point?
Bullshit!
What's bullshit?
Enemy leaders can play bullshit cards during combat to gain an unfair advantage.
Bullshit powers are limited to only a few uses, but they're really powerful.
Just now, Kyle just upgraded one of his elven swarmers to a vampire.
What the f-?
There's va- There's vampires in my fucking fantasy, mythical shit?
What is this?
Increased health and new attacks.
What?
Vampires?
I thought we're Lord of the Rings!
There's no vampires in my Lord of the Rings ripoff!
Okay, get him.
Get him.
Team Edward.
Vampires are fantasy.
Yeah, but it's medieval fantasy.
We're being like, stickier here.
That's why it's bullshit.
It's Castlevania now.
So, as you can see, we've had to make some changes to the game because some asshole who we won't name decided to become all powerful and ruin the stick of truth.
Not me.
That's different, you kid.
So then we played superheroes and guess what happened?
That same someone got all OP again and fucking ruined that game too.
And now because of that someone- Not my fault you're bad at the game, Cartman.
And then once there were rules, everyone started arguing over the rules.
And then we all went to war again.
Remember, with this new card-based system, you're only as powerful as the cards in your hand.
And you only get two to start with.
Yeah, because aliens are real!
I'm sure you'll manage.
Don't worry.
I don't need to ruin this game if the game ruined it himself.
Because this is America.
So, you are now the king of two cards.
Congratulations.
That's me!
Now, Libby.
Clyde has information that the elves-
Yeah, you heard that?
I'm the real one.
Yeah, me.
I have Cray.
What?
The best new kid to me.
You're the important one.
But I have Cray!
Good luck!
How can I not be number one?
I paid like $20 more than the other regular children!
That's actual bullshit!
What's the point of paying more money if I'm not number one?
Three plus one.
Why am I always wife number four?
Come here and I'll show you how to wage war on my behalf.
And bring your friends.
If they're not pussies.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is my war table.
You can choose your mission on the map.
And tell me when you're ready to head to the front lines.
If you want to join someone else's game, you can totally just be a follower.
Okay.
Select matchmaking button.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
I want to talk to the other kids.
Here, take a look.
Oh, these are like the upgrades that you can get.
Meet your typical baby.
Select the psycho radians to see how they scale.
Pretty neat, huh?
Okay.
And then change levels.
Select the option train with brothers again by selecting tutorial buttons.
What do you mean?
I'm talking about the books of laws.
Thank God.
Okay.
I was like, I actually don't want to do the tutorial.
Alright, let's see.
What else is there?
Is this like the lobby?
Oh, hey, Tweek!
Hey, Tweek.
What is this?
Come back with at least 50pp.
Is that toilet paper?
Tweek and I run the shop together.
He handles the finances.
Oh my gosh, so romantic.
I love... I don't know if you guys ever watched the episode where they like hooked them up.
But they actually use like real fan art.
Like real like shipping fan art for their episode.
Like they didn't draw that.
They were like, hey guys, if you're like a Tweek live shipper, send us some fan art so we can...
Oh my God.
You're a new kid, aren't you?
It's me, Mr. Hankey.
I thought you got fucking phased out.
I brought some Christmas magic with me.
You want some?
I would never thought I'd see 3D Mr. Hankey.
I can give you a taste if you want.
I don't know how comfortable.
I am about this.
What is it, Dark Matter perks?
What the fuck is this?
either way you can head back to the war table whenever you're prepared.
And if you bring it here, you can use it to expand yourself past your limits.
Give it a try.
I want to be stronger.
Yeah, I want to be stronger with bows.
We bought this game?
Keep taking in that damage!
And you don't know about Mr. Hankey?
He's the Christmas spirit!
Because we all have a little Mr. Hankey inside of us.
No matter what.
He's the Christmas spirit!
Alright, let's see.
Armor!
Oh, this is like gear and stuff.
Alright, what's this?
Oh, look at that!
A toolkit!
Hahaha!
Oh?
Not prepared.
Wizard staff?
Oh!
A lot of fireballs that burn many targets at once.
Charge up for it.
Oh, I want to try magic!
Ah, yes.
Tolkien.
It's always been Tolkien.
Do you know like, ever since the Tolkien episode, they like, they...
They like, changed the...
They changed every official, like, Wikipedia episode guide.
Like, every official online information about Tolkien to Tolkien.
The moment that episode...
This is like, actual gaslighting.
Hahaha!
Yeah, they switched the subtitles.
It's actually crazy that they went through all that.
Leave the matchmaking...
Okay, hold.
I won.
Woo!
Okay, and then...
Hold and release.
Oh, I can like, do like a strong fire blast too.
How do I leave the matchmaking?
Do I just like...
Oh, I just have to queue up and then release it again.
Banana, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Mr. Hanky is just talking about probiotics.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can join someone else's game if you want.
Not everyone is cut out for the glory of leadership.
Alright.
Just mark your name here if you want backup that bad.
I want to...
Alright.
Alright, I wanna host a game.
Host.
Wait, can I... Oh, chapter one!
We're gonna do super hard.
How hard can that be as a kid's game?
Like, it's a game set in a children's town.
It can't be that hard.
Select a chapter?
Wait, can I not host game?
What the fuck?
How do I host a game?
How do I...
No!
How do I host it?
Oh, I'm still in the tutorial?
The tutorial never ended?
Like, what?
What do you mean the tutorial never ended?
Wait...
Wait, do you...
Oh, there we go.
I'm hosting, guys.
Alright, begin hosting.
Okay.
Everyone can join!
But I'm number one.
Okay, cause I'm the real new kid.
You're not the real new kid.
I don't even know how to...
Is that it?
Is that...
Did I host it?
Like, tutorial...
You have to pre-order...
I did!
I actually pre-ordered!
I actually pre-ordered for this.
Privacy set to public.
Okay, nice.
And I think that's it, right?
Alright.
Anyone can join my game.
Do I have to wait?
Do I have to wait to start this?
Or like...
Is everything already started?
I don't know.
I don't know!
Can people join now?
Like...
Guys!
Guys, are you really gonna make me do hard level all by myself?
I'm the only one who bought the game.
No.
There's no other kids.
I am the only new kid!
Current player is me.
Look at that, guys!
Look at all these open slots!
Oh my god!
Guys!
Single file chat!
Guys, please!
One at a time!
Guys!
Oh my god!
One at a time!
Don't worry!
You don't have to take your time!
Chat!
You're...
Please!
Single file, everybody!
Single file!
I know!
It's so crazy!
You get to play!
It's snow day!
We're all here!
Let's go!
What do you mean?
Carmen, wait up!
We gotta wait for the dragoons!
Carmen!
What do you mean?
We gotta wait for the dragoons!
Guys, people were just in a car jam.
And it was traffic.
Chat.
There was just traffic.
Everybody.
Chat.
Carmen, who are these assholes?
They're my secret army.
The secret army.
Me.
Chat.
I saw your army gearing up for battle.
The army of one.
They're just stuck in the tutorial.
Chat.
Are you serious?
Remember, there's no fighting allowed at the Bullshit Trial.
This is sacred ground.
Chat.
Yeah, yeah.
Just get on with it, butters.
Chat.
Each player lays down a Bullshit card.
So that we can all get out of here.
My friends are in the middle of school.
Chat.
I just moved.
I'm a new kid.
Chat.
They're at another school.
As the keeper of rules, it is my honor to preside over this Bullshit Trial.
Chat.
Begin your selection.
After birth, thank you.
Chat.
Don't let the elves have any of you, new kid.
Quick, everyone, don't join so she becomes paranoid about how hosting works.
Chat.
Don't let the elves have any of you, new kid.
Okay, I need that rare.
Chat.
I don't have enough TP for upgrades.
Summon a...
Chat.
What the fuck?
Why are these cards better?
Chat.
Oh, that's like...
Is that my bullshit?
Chat.
Your entire team emits noxious fumes to gross out enemies.
Summon...
Chat.
That fight for you.
You become invisible.
Chat.
Okay, I need to summon minions because apparently Chat.
I'm just an army of fucking one.
Chat.
So...
Where'd you get those?
Chat.
This is your last chance to back off, new kid.
Elven immortality.
Chat.
Nature's power.
Enemies become giants?
Chat.
Why do they have two Bullshits?
It's because they're...
Chat.
Elves?
Fucking elves.
Chat.
That's right.
That's why you have no human rights.
Chat.
Because you're not even human.
Okay, we can see like what cards they have.
Chat.
Okay, nice.
They really have two!
Chat.
They have two cards!
Give us the toilet paper!
Chat.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, to summon this I have to hold R.
Where the fuck are the elves?
God, I'm by myself.
I don't feel good about this.
Everyone is with you in spirit.
That's good to know, guys!
I'm glad you're there in spirit!
Just, you know, it's great!
Okay.
Let's find your kids.
I'm like at least in, what, fourth grade or fifth grade?
I can't tell.
I'm like eternally stuck in like elementary school.
So I'm like third... I'm like fourth or fifth grade.
But I know these children are kindergartners.
That's right.
Oh my god!
I have friends!
They don't have names, guys, because they're not the main character.
See, I told you!
Guys, I told you!
They were stuck in traffic!
They don't have names because it's a bug, chat.
They don't have names.
It's a bug.
It's a bug!
That's why you don't see any names.
Wait, where did they go?
Sorry, they had to go back home.
Sorry, guys.
They had to like go home because...
There was like issues with the internet.
So they had to get the internet fixed.
Don't worry.
I called in reinforcements.
My new...
My new Dragoon friends are gonna come over, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna beat this guy up.
I don't know if there's like fall damage.
Is there fall damage in this game?
Oh, friends!
I told you they're back!
They fixed the internet!
Internet has been fixed!
Chat!
Okay, I need to put the totem down.
Guys, snack break.
Snack break, guys.
Snack break.
Yeah, this is the new self-parking.
Oh, I need to grab some toilet paper.
Why do all these children have toilet paper?
I'm like confused about that.
Okay, how do I get up?
Oh, no.
Okay, I have to parkour up here.
Are these...
Yeah, they are!
Alright, who's in my...
Who's in my lobby right now?
Tell me right now, guys.
I know you're not lying.
Because these people are real.
I know you're real, guys.
Who's in my lobby?
Me?
See?
Broku!
I fucking knew it!
I knew Broku was in my...
That's the guy that's number two.
Choose your upgrade.
Okay, do I have...
I don't have...
God, I don't even have money.
Fuck yeah, I'll do extended aura.
It's rare.
Okay, we're gonna grab...
See?
I'm in their game too!
I told you.
I told you they're real dragoons.
I told you my dragoons who go to another school were real.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So nice of the dragoons to help you on your quest.
I know, right?
You guys didn't see them in the lobby because they were busy like connecting to the internet.
The dragoons that got into my lobby, they have really shitty internet.
So they cut in and out.
The young ones are always the most vicious.
Oh my god, there's so many of the fucking kids.
Oh my god, why are they all Ls?
Why don't they all want to join the cool human squad?
Goddamn Kylo.
Propaganda.
It got to them.
There's always like this like question of like who would win.
You versus like a hundred elementary kids.
Not the bow.
All right, here you go.
It's not even a bow.
It's a fucking...
No, who put bullshit?
What do they do?
Reanimate?
I literally killed one guy.
I like how they put the bullshit thing out and it was literally one guy.
That's fine.
That's fine with me.
It was one guy.
I'm fine with that.
Kyle, you fucking idiot.
I only killed one person.
Okay.
Let's just head him over here.
I feel like bows would be better.
I don't know.
The...
Oh, I can have my dragoons kill all of them.
My very real dragoons.
Go my very real dragoons.
Wait, are they eternal?
No, they're not.
Do they also get stunned by the mud?
They do.
Okay, we're fine.
It's fine.
I have totem pole.
I don't have...
Snack break!
They're so real.
They are.
It's just bugging out that the name isn't on there.
Guys, this game literally just came out, chat.
This game literally just came out.
There's like, you know, there's like features there that's not like properly implemented.
So like, day one, day one...
No!
I can't use my fucking heals!
I can't use my heals again!
We just gotta accept that day one is not perfect.
They just undamaged.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's stream sniper mode on.
I had stream sniper mode on.
So...
Oh, the goth kids?
Why are the goth kids here?
Do you seek the powers of those beyond our plane?
Hello, Henrietta.
Hey, Doki, you're so cool.
Can I borrow $30?
For asking you to the super chat?
Thank you.
All right.
What do you want, goth kid?
Hey, Jimmy asked for my money.
I want my help with your like game or whatever.
These are dark ritual cards.
They can manifest power beyond the mundane.
But some of them come at a price.
It's up to you what you're willing to sacrifice for wealth and power.
Anyway, go ahead and like pick one.
What is this?
Bottomless?
Replenish all zero expended bullshit uses.
Join powers of deception.
Raise the level of all upgrade cards by one.
Sacrifice extended dark aura for 60 dark matter.
Wait, what?
Dark aura for 60 dark matter.
Do I want dark matter?
I feel like...
Raise the level of all your upgrade cards.
I feel like I don't really need that.
My dragoons will be fine.
Sacrifice to the darkness.
Nice.
There's not much to do around here.
That's fine.
My very real dragoons don't need extra healing.
Okay, I'm at Stark's Pop.
My very real dragoons will be fine.
Hard difficulty is for babies.
Fucking calling me journalist mode.
What is this?
Wait, where do I go?
Why is there...
Do I go to the ice?
They're real!
Why does no one believe me?
My dragoons go to another school in Canada.
Sorry, in America.
I'm sorry.
My very real dragoons in America.
Oh, thank God.
You gotta help me.
Randy?
Lord?
I got stuck in the ice.
But I hit the jackpot.
Look at all this toilet paper.
You gotta find a way to break the ice and get me out of here.
Hurry, my balls are bleeding.
Wait, he has a nose?
Elven treasure.
This looks like a trap.
I bet Kyle's behind this.
Oh, yeah, Kyle.
Yeah, I can help you get Kyle.
Just get him out of here.
I'll give you some treasure, too.
Oh, no, he's stuck.
This is Tegrity Farms, Randy?
Or Pre-Tegrity Farms?
I'm gonna say it.
I don't like Tegrity Farms, Randy.
I miss old Randy.
Find gas and keys.
Where is the fuck is...
Why can't I just burn him out?
I have fire.
Actually, I miss old Randy.
I think Tegrity Farms, Randy is like...
They...
They pushed too hard on the character.
No DLC in this standard.
Wait, what's that?
There's like stuff here.
There's like stuff over there.
What is that?
Is that bowling ball?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, that is a bowling ball.
Elves must have run off somewhere.
Can I not free this?
This is literally fireball magic.
It's real fireball magic.
Yeah, I miss old Randy.
I think like that's like...
One of the changes I didn't like with the new South Park.
I'm like okay with the new South Park, but like Tegrity Farms, Randy was just too much.
I think they did like...
I think it ruined the Randy character for me.
Because they tried to make him like...
They tried...
Because now they just...
It's just too much Randy.
It's too much Randy.
But it's not like good Randy too.
What are you doing?
You barbecuing?
Wait, how do I do this?
Entering campsite.
What the fuck was the bowling ball for?
I don't know what the bowling ball for.
Yeah, my...
Me and my real dragoons are going to kick your ass.
They have shields now!?
What the fuck?
Dragons!
My very real dragolins!
Where are you?
What?
How are they doing that?
Guys!
There you are!
I know you guys were here!
I knew you guys came!
I told you!
I told you they're real!
The internet got out.
Look, it was an internet issue but they're here now!
They're here now, chat!
Look!
Look, there they are!
There they are!
The dial-up!
It worked!
I'm sorry, a lot of them are on dial-up right now.
Mom had to use the phone.
Mom had to use the phone but they're here now.
Remember when Annie was on the wheel of the fort?
No!
Not the real Annie!
The wheel of the fort!
No!
We're just playing.
Okay.
Alright, get over here.
Get over here.
I'm trying my best to kill the healer dragoons!
What are you trying to say?
Australian internet.
Yeah, yeah.
One of them is on Australian internet.
The other is on dial-up.
And then the other two, they're using data right now to play in America.
So that's why they're cutting in and out.
I have to wait for them.
My very real dragoons.
AOL dragoons.
Yay!
We gotta find the key.
Oh wait, there's like toilet paper here.
Toilet paper.
Nice.
Alright, toilet paper.
They're in the tunnel.
Yeah, every time they disappear, they're going through a tunnel.
Chat.
It makes perfectly sense.
See?
Oh no, they drove through a tunnel again.
Ziplining is stupid.
Elves are stupid.
It all makes sense.
Don't get distracted by the ziplines.
They look way more fun than they are.
The elves probably hid the keys in the back near the office.
Why are they hiding Randy's keys?
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god.
DRAGOONS!
GET OUT OF THE TUNNEL!
DRAGOONS THE TUNNEL!
OH MY GOD!
ONE OF THEM IS OUT OF THE TUNNEL NOW!
Nice.
Look at them.
They came out of the fucking... you can tell they were in the tunnel because they just suddenly lagged in.
You can tell.
Look at that.
They're back.
What the fuck was that?
Oh, it's the magic.
It's the magic elves.
Okay, don't worry.
I have fire.
Don't worry.
Where the fuck are the other... wait, where the... why do I only have two friends?
Wait, why do I only have two friends?
Do I only have two viewers?
Me and my two viewers.
That's fine.
Even if Doki has one fan, I'm one of them.
If Doki has zero fans, it's because I'm dead.
Only the real homies are here.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta get over there.
How the fuck do I get over there?
Oh wait, there's the gopkin!
I don't know.
That's a real... a real goon right there.
Oh my god, fucking hiding in the snowman?
Those are elf tactics.
Fight me like a real human!
That's fucking right.
So real.
Okay.
Wait, how the fuck did this dragon get up there?
How did you guys get up there?
Alright, let me grab some loot real fast.
Alright.
Let me grab this.
And then... talk to the goth kid.
Hello.
I would like some upgrades, please.
Prince of Ravens grants 20 dark matter.
Replenish all zero.
Grants 100 toilet paper?
Okay, 100 toilet paper.
Well, it makes sense.
Remember, the real power comes from inside.
Wait, number two has a name!
Oh my god!
I mean, they were... I mean...
I told you it was a bug!
I knew they were real all along!
Can't believe you came in.
But maybe you can find another way up and over the tree.
What do you mean he's actually real?
They've always been real.
They've always been real, chat.
What the fuck do you mean?
Oh my god, they hot fixed it!
Chat, they hot fixed the game!
Now you can actually see the names!
Is that fucking crazy?
Where the fuck am I going?
They're real.
I told you.
No one believed my dragoons that go to school in America.
No one believed.
Well, sucks to be them.
Wait, who the fuck is this guy?
There's an invisible elf.
There's an invisible elf right here.
We will be fine.
We collected the keys.
We can leave now.
Let's go!
Wait, it's snowed in.
We can't leave.
Never mind.
Apparently we actually have to kill all of you guys.
Alright, give me a sec.
We have to apparently kill all of them.
I knew it.
I fucking... everyone called me crazy.
Everyone fucking called me crazy about my dragoons that go to school in America.
Alright, nice.
Is that all of them?
No, we have to kill all these elves!
Who the fuck wants to be an elf?
Oh my gosh, how do I get over there?
How do I get over there?
Oh my god, how the fuck do I get over there?
Okay.
I did it!
This is it!
We got this!
We got this, my real dragoon!
We're gonna do this together!
No, the shield.
The shield, people.
What do you mean?
I can deal with this!
Okay.
Nice, we got this.
You know what?
I think I might have to use...
I think I have to use this.
It's bullshit time!
Oh, victory.
We did it.
Alright.
Alright, now...
It's okay.
They're moral support.
We have the moral support.
My moral support crew.
Where the fuck is the exit?
I'm lost already.
I'm already lost.
Do I have time to go home and pee?
What the fuck?
No!
You're not paid to pee!
Number two!
Where do I...
It's like Codename Kid's next door.
Where do we go, number two?
Where do we go?
Not... Is it really... There's no way it's this way.
Come on, my very real dragoon.
Where the fuck do we go?
Weeeeee!
We... Oh shit, there's like...
Oh shit, wait, there's crosshairs that tell us where to go.
You're so smart.
Alright, what can we upgrade?
Let us upgrade.
Fully charged costs five health?
Yeah, no.
Damaging and bleeding enemies makes you 38% more pissed off.
The staff now fires.
Three orbs.
Ooooooh!
This is really more of an action game than a thinking game.
Okay, we actually know.
It's like reduce 66% damage.
I'd rather just get this and upgrade.
I'm gonna upgrade this.
You got it, Bob.
Alright.
Damaging and bleeding enemies makes you 50% more pissed off.
Let's go.
I wanna be more angry.
What did we get?
Pool expanded?
Nice!
We got more of the pool!
We gotta get the gas!
There's a cannon.
Now you can break that block of ice with a cannonball.
Oh, wait!
Oh, that's how you break the fucking ice block!
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, where's the bowling ball?
Let me grab some toilet paper real fast.
I can't believe these people will throw away good toilet paper in the fucking trash can!
They're the new currency!
That's a pretty sweet card.
Don't fuck it up.
Gnome gaming.
You always get gnomed.
Alright, we have to throw this here?
Search how I throw the bowling ball.
Like, do I throw the bowling ball like...
No!
My very real trap!
No, it's...
He's like in the tunnel!
He's in a tunnel, chat!
Guys, he didn't leave!
It's the internet!
Grab my...
They didn't leave, it was just the internet!
Chat...
It was just the internet.
It's the internet!
Where the fuck do I drop the bowling ball?
There's a cannon?
Where is the cannon?
There's a cannon?!
There was a cannon here all along?!
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
God damn it.
It's okay.
I know your internet caused you to disconnect.
You have plenty of time to rejoin me.
My very real dragoon.
Alright.
Oh!
That's the cannonball!
Alright, let's pick it up and put it in.
Oh yeah.
Oh god, I actually have to walk up the stairs.
I can't believe it.
It's like I'm a child.
I can't believe I actually have to walk up and can't even jump.
Alright, load.
What the fuck do I shoot?
This?
Oh!
That's what I shoot!
Okay.
And then...
Grab some more.
Oh, we can have another cannonball.
There was a cannonball right there.
I did not have to kill it.
I didn't have to walk this far.
Yay!
For me?
It's my birthday.
Do you guys know that?
Because every day is my birthday.
Yay!
Nice!
The one I've always wanted!
Toilet paper!
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is this?
Overlook point.
What the fuck is that over there?
What is that over there?
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, I got more dark matter.
Is this lady okay?
I posted my broken leg on social media and it got so many likes!
Bro, what the fuck?
Oh no, she's an influencer.
We don't go near those people.
Jimmy, look away.
That's an influencer.
Don't go near them.
Alright, she's fine.
She's just influencing.
Grab the gas can, you kid.
It's right there.
Alright, I'm gonna grab it.
Well, you're fucked.
Oh, no!
No!
It was a trap!
Who would have thought?
It was a trap all along!
I can't believe it.
How could we have known that?
How could we have known that it was a trap?
It was a trap!
Okay.
Nice.
We're okay.
No, no!
Please not be reanimated.
No!
Times 11!
Oh, it's okay.
My very real dragoons, go and do your thing!
You'll be fine!
You'll be okay!
I'll go deal with the archers!
Alright.
I think matchmaking is only the location lock.
Wait, is it really?
Oh my god.
That's funny.
You gotta be Canadian to play with me, I guess.
Except for my very real American dragoons.
I got an exception.
Those are...
Except for the very real American dragoons.
Those are actual Americans.
Those are... those are actual!
You know I got knocked out.
Get up close to him to help him escape.
It's okay.
We gotta...
Good job, keep each other safe out there.
Don't worry, we're fine.
We're so fine.
Teammate down?
That's okay!
My other dragoons can save him!
Oh god.
I need a healer!
Oh, yeah!
Woah!
Oh!
Save me!
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
I told you hard difficulty is nothing.
It's fine.
Revive them!
Oh, wait.
I'm already getting healed.
That's fine.
It's okay.
Then you guys can play with all the other dragoons.
Alright.
Where's my teammates?
Oh, he's over there.
Ow!
No!
You got me!
Alright.
There you go.
We're fine.
I couldn't block it!
Yay!
Look at all this beautiful toilet paper!
Woah!
They're in the tunnel again.
I just love how every time...
Every time the fight is over...
What a coincidence!
They're in the tunnel again.
Guys.
What a fucking coincidence.
Woah!
Oh my god!
How the fuck do you already so...
What the fuck?
You have a shield?
This man played a game before I played a game.
Okay.
What do I have?
Uncommon.
It shoots to...
You know I'm a reshuffle.
I don't like these cards.
Uncommon.
Enemies drop... Oh!
Money!
Yes!
Can I promote it?
Yeah, I'm gonna promote it.
I'm gonna bribe him.
Now 90% more toilet paper?
That's so much more toilet paper.
Uh, do I still... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Um...
I need about 350.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to travel.
Where are we?
Oh, we're back!
You won't leave me like the other Dragoon, right?
Wait, wait.
Before we do that, we have to...
Wait, there's a chest!
I bowling balled the chest!
Give me a sec.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
Look at all this toilet paper!
Alright.
I got everything we need.
We need to...
Put the gas in the can.
Wait, did you already do it?
Did you already do it, Dragoon?
Oh no.
I have to deliver it.
Where do I start it?
Oh, I start the truck.
It's okay.
I have a license.
I got it when I was 7.
Nice.
What the fuck?
I thought he was like in the water.
Where's Randy?
Are you okay, Randy?
I used to meet you.
I did it.
Under my guidance and sage-like wisdom.
Oh, thank god.
You did it.
You saved me.
I've been trapped in here all day.
I would have gotten out, but there's a level 3 elven lock on that door over there.
What?
I'm so happy.
I found this chest full of toilet paper.
Everyone in town is hoarding this stuff.
Especially that damn Stotch.
It's worth more than money.
I'm rich.
I'm richer than Stotch.
You can't.
Let's find out where Kyle's hiding.
Uh, yeah.
Kyle.
Yeah.
I can show you where he is.
But, uh...
Oh, man.
I've been stuck here so long.
I really gotta go take a shit.
Just, uh, look within yourself and you'll find all the answers you need.
You know?
Believe in yourself and all that stuff.
It'll be revealed.
I'm gonna go take a shit and rub this toilet paper in that fucking Stotch's face.
What?
This is the end for you.
They fucking locked us in!
Downstage an ambush.
Make them regret it, new kid.
They're taking the high ground, dumbass.
Just jump over it!
I can fucking find my way out of it!
I don't understand!
What's the point of having the fucking chosen power?
Like, holy shit.
It's like the...
The end's arrived.
It's like... It's like Mr. Adult Man right there.
Fucking heading to the movie theater.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Not the... Not the end!
No!
Okay.
Yeah.
Here we go.
We don't need health.
We're gonna live forever.
It was at this moment.
Don't you rea- What the fuck?!
Holy shit!
I almost got fucked up there!
Bros, you- don't mess with trees.
They give us tree powers.
They give us toilet paper.
Don't mess with the trees.
Okay.
We have healers though.
We're good.
Oh my god!
You got magic w- Bro!
He's actually dead!
Wait!
Oh no.
That's just his makeup.
Okay.
I thought you burned him into a skull or some shit.
I was like, oh my god.
That was gonna be hardcore.
Hi!
They so- No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
They're so strong!
Oh no!
Heal me!
The chosen one!
Number one!
It's okay.
I'm getting healed.
You guys do all the work.
I'm gonna get healed right now.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna- I'm gonna stay there.
Alright.
It's fine.
Yeah, I don't care about this UFO cause it's canon!
Ow!
Alright.
We gotta get rid of the fucking arrows.
Oh fudge!
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
That's fucking right.
You can't fucking fuck me up this time.
I can dodge!
Another wave from the UFO!
What's the supersize?
Oh!
He big!
Okay.
I'm just gonna- Yeah, I'm just gonna start using my- Oh!
What the fuck?!
Why is this paladin so fucking strong?!
The power of the elf gods!
Bro!
I'm like so fucking- Did he like one-shots me?
Oh no.
I need to- I need to stay with the- I need to stay within this range.
It's okay.
My dragoons is gonna do stuff.
I'll just go fucking right click.
I'll just don't get involved.
I don't- I won't get involved anymore.
Oh no.
The trees.
The trees are coming.
It's alright.
I have fire- fire power.
I have my flower power right here.
Man, that level 3 elven lock really locks you in.
Glad to be thinking with a super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I just need to figure out my aim here though.
Oh my god.
What is the drop off- No!
Not the trees!
Get me away from the trees!
Oh wait!
He's still alive!
Look!
Him and the cow is still alive!
Wait.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
They got him.
They got one of him.
Mr. Adult Man.
It's okay.
We can solo him.
Pew!
Trust me.
As long as he doesn't touch me, we're fine.
Pew!
Wait!
You de- Oh!
I'm dead!
Warlord!
Wait!
You're dead!
Oh no!
I'm floating!
Don't float!
Stop!
I'm so- No!
Are you following me?
Just get fucked up.
No!
Where's our NPCs?
It's okay.
I'm hiding down here.
We're fine.
We'll be fine.
Just revive us in here.
They don't know!
No!
NPC!
Yes!
Revive us in here!
I mean!
Real person!
Real goon!
I'm back.
I knew I was back.
I mean the real goon, guys.
I meant the real- Oh my fucking god!
Why is everybody so strong?
It's okay.
It's cause he was playing so bad that I called him an NPC chat.
That's why I called him NPC!
Cause he was playing so fucking shit.
Like you don't understand.
I can't believe it.
Hard was actually hard.
Who would have thought- Who would have thought hard was really hard, guys?
Jesus Christ.
I need to- I'm gonna call for bullshit.
It's bullshit time.
It's bullshit time!
Oh god, I need to heal myself.
I need to heal myself.
Jesus Christ.
Get over here.
Where the fuck are you?
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it.
Who would have thought?
We survived.
Don't worry, I can unscathed.
I should pick this level 3 pick.
Jimmy, what are you doing?
Jimmy, what are you doing here?
You could have unlocked this door this whole time.
The staff orb bounces twice.
Impact doing...
Oh wait, I like that.
It does a double bounce.
Bye.
No, no, no, no, no.
I need to grab this.
Toilet paper.
And then we just drop...
A hideout!
100% more toilet paper?
I'll be here all week.
Or at least until school reopens.
That's like 100% more money!
You don't get it.
They are a rule.
The elves do unspeakable things to trees to gain their dark powers.
Holy shit, these trees.
These trees, man.
Oh my god, it's the elf king.
It's Kyle.
That fucking elf.
You see...
You're not a real king.
A real king will stand behind the lines and then make everybody else do all the work for him.
Just like Cartman.
That's why he's a real king.
Oh shit, okay.
That was on me.
Holy fuck.
How do I get to you?
Guys, it took me 20 years, but I got to him finally.
It took me a while.
A real king will stand behind enemy lines and make other people do the dirty work for us.
That's why Cartman is my real king.
Right here.
Jesus Christ, this is...
Why is this boss fight so hard?
Holy shit.
I'm so sorry.
Why is it so...
I can barely get to this fucker.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Hard mode is actually hard mode.
The moment I get to him, he's already like traveled 20 meters away from me.
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
I'm just gonna predict.
I'm gonna do some fucking prediction shit.
Okay, he's gonna...
Oh, he's not moving.
Okay, where is he gonna move?
Oh, he's over there.
I fucking knew it.
I knew you were gonna be over there.
Are you serious?
Where did you go?
It's okay.
No, it's not.
Why am I here?
It's okay.
He has to go here.
No, he's not.
He's over there.
He's over here.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking activating bullshit.
I don't have bullshit.
No!
Where did he go?
Kyle, please!
Let me at least fucking hit you one time.
I don't care.
Alright, here we go.
Oh no.
Okay.
I need heal.
Please.
That's illegal!
This is illegal!
My fucking snack time!
You don't hit a person when it's snack time!
Those are kindergarten rules.
You never hit somebody during snack hours.
Where did he go?
Where the fuck?
Okay, there he is.
Yoooooo!
Alright.
No!
Heal, heal, heal, heal, heal.
It's so dishonorable!
Okay.
Oh no.
Here we go.
We're okay.
It's still snack time hours.
Okay.
Nice.
We got him.
He's running!
He's a coward!
He's so scared!
Oh, I'm so scared.
Snack time!
He can't teleport anymore!
He's scared!
He can't teleport!
We can do this!
He lost all his powers!
Go after him!
Oh, he teleported, chat.
Who would've thought he teleported?
Who would've thought?
Oh my god, he's one bar.
He's one bar.
This is it.
Woooo!
Oh my god, please.
Please get closer.
Please!
Please, he's one hit!
He's so close to dying!
Oh, why did I dive into that?
I'm just gonna use my staff.
Where did he go?
No!
He's got this.
I got this!
I've got him!
Yes!
Easy.
So fucking easy.
Yes!
Yes, I did it!
You know what, Kyle?
I learned something today.
You're a little bitch.
Fuck you, Carmel.
Yay!
We did it!
We killed Kyle!
Yay!
When are we gonna meet Kenny?
When are we gonna meet Princess Kenny?
There's a chest!
Okay.
Snack break.
I'm gonna open this chest first.
We have a little snack break!
Snack break!
Alright.
Is there like any more loot that we're missing?
Is there any more loot?
I think we're fine.
Alright, I'm coming over!
No!
Yay!
We did it.
I knew we were gamers.
Look at that.
Look at all these fucking achievements we made.
Together.
Dragons.
Proceed.
What the fuck does...
Oh, dark matter.
I got the most damage done.
Look at that.
I had the most DPS.
Is it lore time?
Those are the rules, right, your honor?
Those are the rules, yes.
You didn't beat me, fat ass.
The new kid did.
And who are those other three kids they were playing with?
Oh, those were the other new kids.
Yeah.
They all think they're the actual new kid, but...
Yeah, I'm the one that matters.
I'm number one.
That's why I'm always the host.
Honestly, those other new kids are all throwing corners at me.
You're all just minor copies of me.
Why did you attack my fucking base?
Attack your base?
Ha!
Are you denying that you were gearing up your entire army to attack our fucking base?
Yeah!
Says who?
Says Clyde!
Yeah!
And do you always trust what Clyde says?
Yeah, because he's not an elf!
Yeah!
God damn it, you guys!
We are gearing up to attack someone else!
Someone who I think is a real, actual threat to our town!
What?
Worse than elves?
And gingers?
A snowstorm this big?
In one weekend?
Have you ever seen anything like it?
What are you suggesting, elf?
It isn't natural.
I think that someone has cast a level 10 endless winter spell.
That kind of magic has been outlawed ever since I was a kid.
Since the new kid ruined the last game by farting backwards in time!
Yeah, well it's been done.
I know it.
What?
Who would do such a thing?
The same person who's been acting strange for the past week.
Stan.
Stan has been acting strange ever since he thought his version of the rules were best.
Where is Stan?
Must be ManBearPig.
But then the new kid came and got in the way.
Wow, nice going, new kid.
What?
What the fuck did I do?
It's been no fun and games for you guys, but this storm isn't going to end.
And our town is in serious trouble.
Oh, jeez.
Then we have no choice.
New kid, we must get to the marsh walker, Stan.
And find out what he's been hiding.
Stan's gonna be evil?
You're loaded with dark matter.
Oh my god.
Integrity Farms fucked him up, man.
Alright, it's time to go to the lobby.
Oh my god, now he's part of my team.
Looks like your mystical powers have grown.
About time.
Go to Tolkien.
Let him guide you.
Oh, I got new powers.
Where are my new powers?
Now that your powers have grown, let's take a closer look.
Alright.
Select the powers tab.
Oh, I can have like new powers now.
I don't have to heal you guys anymore.
Uh...
Fast yourself...
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Actually...
I feel like I'm gonna have to shield.
What the fuck is the cat?
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, what kind of...
Ooh.
Wild areas and flames.
Oh my god!
This is the one that you have!
My real dragoon!
It's like a flamethrower!
Actually, I don't know.
I'm gonna try this.
I'm gonna try a flamethrower.
That seems really cool.
Create a shield.
Alright.
Nice.
I have a shield now.
Alright.
Hey guys!
I'm gonna try this.
Guys, I know you guys so wanna play.
Dragoons, one at a time!
Dragoons!
One at a time in this very public lobby!
Whoa!
I can fucking...
look cooler?
...
Okay.
I have 60 PP.
But like...
I don't know, but like...
I need people to know I paid the extra $20.
Like...
I need people to know that.
Ooh, I could be like...
I can have a tiny crown.
No, but I want people to get gnomed.
Alright, let's see.
I could... wait, what is this?
Is that the capes and stuff?
Oh, the emotes!
Wait, how do I even use emotes?
Just buy what speaks to you.
Wait, what is this?
How do I see...
Okay, let's see.
Oh, Swifting!
What the fuck is Swifting?
Purchase Gola, Tantrum, Twinkle Toes, Spin, Peanut Butters, Tap Dance...
Uh... I'm gonna buy...
I'm gonna buy Swif... I'm gonna buy Swifting.
I wanna know what Swifting is.
Alright.
How do I use my emotes, guys?
How do I...
How do I use...
You guys know how to use the emotes in this game?
Is it T?
Is that Fortnite?
B?
How the fuck do I use the emotes?
Okay, we're gonna have to...
Remap controls.
Okay.
Use bullshit.
What the fuck is... who... who...
Oh, Emo Wheel Z!
Okay.
What the fuck is Toot... oh.
Okay, I found the Toot button.
Yeah!
Got $20!
Guys.
I figured...
I figured... guys.
I figured out what Toot was.
Woo!
Okay, wait.
What's this?
Oh, I can be Snoopy.
And then...
Look at me go.
I'm so fucking happy.
Toot toot toot to live.
Alright, let's see.
What do we upgrade?
I feel like we need more HP.
And then... you can get 20% more pissed off.
Nice!
I have issues!
Let's go!
Never seek help.
Let's continue having problems.
Alright.
Hey guys!
Like I said.
One at a time!
Matchmaking is open everybody!
Alright.
Oh, this is like all the cards that I currently have.
Like I said everybody!
One at a time!
I know there's so many people that wanna join us!
Slow down dragons!
Slow down!
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
Get over here, Death Warlock!
Get over here!
Fine!
We'll have it on hard!
Time to set a battle plan.
Alright, start the run.
Alright, I'm ready.
Get over here.
Death Warlock!
Get over here!
I can't start the mission!
So you're stuck waiting because of one inconsiderate asshole.
Yeah!
Guys!
One at a time guys!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is this guy?
Where the fuck happened?
He's creeping you!
Bro!
Where the fuck are you?
Move!
Get out of the tunnel!
Okay.
Guys, Death Warlock is in the tunnel right now.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Okay.
I hate to die.
I hate to do this.
I hate to do this to you.
I have to start my lobby.
I need to start the lobby.
You have to put him down.
Don't look!
I took him behind the barn.
I had to take him outside.
I had to take him behind the barn.
Don't worry.
He's gonna come back.
I took him to the farm downstate.
Alright.
He's at the farm downstate right now.
Alright, here we go.
One at a time, Dragus.
I know you're all stuck in that traffic jam.
I know you're all in that tunnel chat.
I know you're all in that fucking tunnel right now.
But please, don't overload the servers chat.
Don't overload the servers.
I know it's so hard in demand.
Where the fuck is it?
Listen.
Sen.
We know you're not gonna win this because your fucking army are not even relevant characters in South Park.
So go ahead and lay out your cards.
Okay, I don't really have a lot of cards.
Your bullshit rules aren't gonna save you, Cartman.
Soon we'll be playing by my rules.
The wand casts chain lightning for...
Oh!
I got chain lightning!
I got chain lightning.
That's pretty OP.
You become invisible and healed up while cloaked.
Your entire team emits noxious fumes to grow so you can jump higher, run forever, and move faster.
Okay, that's a lie.
Like... it runs out.
If I can use it five times, it means I can't run forever.
Like... what the fuck?
It should be one use if I can run forever.
Alright, let's see.
I am...
I think I'm gonna go with the... I'm gonna go with this one.
I think I'm gonna go with the...
I'm gonna go with this one.
That should like... that should like hurt... all of us can hurt them.
You can run forever five times.
Cursed...
Your melee weapons become useless?
What the fuck?
Three... four cards... five cards?!
A plus ten axe?
You can't do that!
I can do it.
I forged it by completing a quest.
It's totally legal.
Ask Butters.
Bro, he went to Home Depot!
Damage grab?
Is a plus ten axe legal?
What?
Kenny?
Okay, who the fuck is... oh, no.
That's like... that's not Kenny.
So, we're still gonna beat the shit out of you.
Ask Kyle how my plus ten wizard balls taste.
Because you're next.
This is bullshit.
Whatever.
Still on the front line, Cartman.
Fucking five cards.
I'm on the front line, son of a bitch.
Yes, five cards!
Okay, so obviously I can't be on the front line, but I'll be in the back casting spells and doing wizard shit to keep you all safe.
Where's my fifty million power?
Alright.
Where do I go?
It's okay, guys.
Don't worry.
The Drago I kicked is definitely coming back.
He still has one more hour left.
I'm the leader of the game.
Oh, I have like...
It's hot.
It's not like fire anymore.
It's like electricity.
Oh, I see.
Wait, this is so OP.
Look at this.
This is actually so OP if I hit the shot.
If I hit the shot, it's so OP, chat.
I swear.
If I hit it.
There I go.
I just electricity forever.
I like...
Okay, yeah.
I just need to wait for the charge.
I just do this.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
It's so OP.
Even if I miss, it's still OP, okay?
It still works.
Pew, pew, pew.
God damn it.
Pew.
Alright.
What the fuck is that pew, pew?
Pew, pew, pew.
Who made that sound?
Where did that sound come from?
Did you guys hear that?
There was no bicycles next to me.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
God, I'm so good.
Nice.
Hard mode is nothing to me.
She's like...
Chat, what do you mean?
I am perfectly okay.
Alright.
I went to therapy yesterday.
Alright, nice.
Alright, dragoons, get over here.
Dragoons.
I need you over here right now.
Okay, I need heal too.
I need a snacky break time.
Oh shit!
Is that dynamite?
Bro!
Is that fucking...
Who gave you dynamite?
What is that?
Oh my god.
Hey!
They have fucking dynamite.
That's a waste of good toilet paper.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Those are...
Those are dynamitrous little students.
Sad!
Bro, DLs are working for them too?
Oh, they're fireworks.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Sand got the illegal...
You can't keep running into air.
Illegal kindergarteners.
Let me go.
Let me go!
He got the sixth graders.
Where am I?
Am I stuck?
Holy shit.
I need to get out of here.
Oh my god.
Who told me to do hard mode?
I don't know.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
How did this game get like...
How did the difficulty spike become like this?
Okay, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Okay, we're good.
We're like four enemies at once.
So we got extra bonus achievements.
Oh god.
Oh god, the sixth graders.
Oh my god.
The sixth graders are here.
Nice.
You can't be invisible.
When I have my magic wand.
They're going for their needs.
Oh, the hockey players.
The sixth graders are coming.
Did you just hit me?
The consequences of my actions.
Oh no.
That was a bad...
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
It's like my...
It's like my fucking dainty wand does nothing.
We have to kill him together.
Smash your knees.
As a team.
Don't wait for that.
He hasn't hit puberty yet.
He's waiting.
We can take him down.
Oh, nice.
Dark matter.
Wait.
What's over there?
Is there a secret?
Oh, there's a secret elf.
There's a secret elf.
No honor.
Oh god.
Wait, he like life steals too.
Okay.
I'm just gonna do this and then zap him from right here.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew, pew.
Jesus Christ.
He's so tanky.
He's actually so tanky.
Here we go.
We have to make sure he doesn't life steal because he's been like living forever because of that.
Hey, it's toilet paper.
Did we kill the sixth grader yet?
Oh no.
Oh no, he's still alive.
Pew, pew, pew.
Wait, what?
Wait, did he...
Wait.
I'm so sorry.
Oh shit.
Who taught you that word?
Whoa.
He cussed in my Christian... very Christian friendly game by the way.
He cussed in my very Christian friendly game.
I can't believe... he said a no-no word.
Come and get it.
Girls?
Oh no.
Guys, I'm very nervous.
I didn't know girls would be playing... would be playing Dungeons and Dragons.
I'm so nervous.
Bullshit.
What's the bullshit?
Oh, it's fine.
I've been using my...
Your weapons are cursed.
From sticks to kind of floppy snakes.
That's okay.
I've never been...
I haven't been using anything else anyway.
I hate you.
Oh shit.
No, not the children.
All right.
Pew, pew, pew.
What were my bullshit?
Okay, then gas.
Okay, I don't need to use it yet.
I'm gonna use... use one of them for Stan.
The marsh walker.
Okay, we need to get over here.
No, I almost used the melee.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
All right.
We gotta get rid of the fireworks.
The fireworks are so...
People are actually really annoying.
No!
Hey!
I can't fly up there!
Hey, free food.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I have to walk all the way up here.
Like a fucking peasant.
Pew, pew, pew.
I can't believe I had to walk like a fucking child.
I am the chosen one.
How could you do this to me?
I'll just stay up here.
Oh, what?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
They're in the fucking snow.
They can climb up?
Who taught you kids how to climb?
Okay, we got...
Oh my...
Okay, Noodle's gone.
Noodle's gone.
Guys, don't worry.
They're not burning to death.
Guys.
It's just all make believe.
It's all make believe.
They're not actually burning to death.
They're actually burning to death.
They'll be fine.
The kids don't actually die.
The final wave is coming.
Where the fuck is the final wave?
It's just pretend, chat.
It's just pretend.
Alright.
How can we find... I don't even know.
I don't even know how people are gonna find my session.
But that's... this is why I'm the host.
I'll always be number one.
Jimmy!
Any upgrades?
They're still co- Who's still alive?
I killed everybody.
I mean like... I pretend killed everybody.
Oh, they're up there.
Alright.
I think it would be a lot easier if I joined somebody's party.
But like...
Oh my god, you were in the fucking snow this entire time.
Can't believe it.
I can't believe it.
I can't even see him.
My magic wand won't let me see.
I need to get him out of the invisibility and then use...
He fucking full healed?
God.
These guys are the worst.
These guys are actually the worst.
They can full heal if they hit us.
No, no.
Don't let him...
Don't let him life steal!
He's 1 HP!
Nice.
Okay.
No.
No, I messed it up.
Wee!
How do I mess that up twice?
Alright.
Yay!
We did it!
Jimmy!
I did it!
Wand flames leave fire patches that last 4 seconds and deals 3 damage.
Uhhhh...
Wait, I feel like the molotov...
Okay, I feel like we should get napalm.
I think that would be really good.
I don't want to waste my money yet.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go, dragoons.
Entering Main Street.
Oh, hey guys!
Find Stan and smash his army.
And then kick him in the bowels if you can.
Here!
Your army won't help you, Cartman!
You're gonna die today!
I said, you're gonna die today!
Yeah, yeah!
You're gonna die today!
What the fuck?
Bro, what?
That's okay, it's just a scratch.
The new kid's dead!
Um, no they're not!
They're only... mostly dead!
Yeah, just a little concussion!
Oh yeah, your axe gave them, um, dysentery.
Dysentery only does 99%...
That's not fair!
Hey, I don't make the rules!
Actually, I kinda do.
Yeah!
What the hell?
It's okay!
I'm just bleeding a little bit out of my head!
You have the potential strength to collect vials of a mysterious gooey step.
And then use the goo to forge an axe.
This isn't fair, Butters!
You have to figure something out so I can beat Stan!
Well, there is an official anything you can do, I can do too clause in the rulebook, so technically...
Who wrote the Book of Laws?
...and get his secret power?
Oh, good!
Do that, new kid!
Finish the quest!
Get powered up!
And stop embarrassing me!
Eeeeee!
I cast a spell, your health is back to 100!
Get the fuck up!
God, I have to do everything around here!
I did it!
My HP is just 100 again!
Good luck!
You're gonna need it!
Yay!
Dun dun dun!
Well, don't scare the new fellas!
Be nice to them!
Stay off the streets?
Oh, I guess like I have to go here.
I'm gonna go this way.
What the fuck?
Remember that Stan has that bullshit axe now!
Touch the ground and you die like lava!
Oh!
Oh, he can use his axe to like kill me!
Really?
What happens if I...
Oh, yeah!
Do I get dysentery again?
It's just a scratch.
It's okay, he only did 99% damage!
Okay, we need to get these guys.
Pew pew pew pew pew!
Ow!
With my stuff?
Yeah!
Am I stuck here?
Okay, there we go.
It's alright.
I can just stay down here.
Oh, I got some stuff here too.
Stay off the streets.
Can I just bone rush this?
I don't level up or anything.
The best I get is like...
I think the best I get is like...
Toilet paper.
Okay, I need to fucking...
I need to fucking heal myself though.
It's alright!
There's fire!
I drop...
Oh, it's not okay!
It's not okay!
Shut up!
It was not okay.
JK.
Okay, I got the snacks right here.
I'll heal right underneath you.
You can't do anything about it.
Oh, player one!
You okay now?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Can't do anything to me.
I thought it would feel different.
Alright, nice.
I guess I'm done playing.
Grabbing some toilet paper.
Oh my god!
She's pretend dead, don't worry.
They're all pretend dead, chat!
Shit, the next roof is too high!
And that catapult has a lock on it!
We'll have to fight to move forward!
Alright, we need to grab some more toilet paper.
I'm crossing it!
Stay off the street.
I think we just have to move forward.
So we'll be fine.
Oh!
Okay, that's my fire.
They have to get into my fire.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Can I unlock it yet?
No!
Not the dysentery!
Where am I?
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Please!
Please, not the dysentery!
Alright, toilet paper is the currency!
Okay, can I pick this lock?
Weeeee!
Keep moving across the rooftops!
Alright, we gotta get across.
And kill Stan the Marsh Walker.
Alright, let's see.
I just beat that shit up?
Oh no, there's a platform right here!
Friends!
Where did my friends go?
How many tunnels are in this driveway?
Where did all my dragoons go?
Friends!
Guys, I swear I have friends.
Guys, I swear.
I swear to God.
They'll show up soon.
They'll show up!
God, the servers have been so unstable, chat!
Wait.
Oh, I need toilet paper here.
Toilet paper.
Alright, here we go.
Well shit, they broke the catapult.
How do we get across now?
Well actually, Erk, I think that there was a trebuchet.
Actually, I think you should shut the fuck up, butters.
We need something stretchy and rubbery to make a new sling.
Get looking, new kid!
What the look?
Where the fuck did I get...
Oh, rubber bands!
Okay, we gotta grab some rubber bands.
Is there like rubber bands behind...
Okay, rubber bands over there.
I'm gonna go back fully first before I...
Oh, I should have upgraded stamina.
I did not realize how much stamina matters until now.
Oh shit, there's actual people down there.
Alright.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew.
That's right.
Burn!
Holy shit!
This fucking napalm shit is so OP.
Yes, new kid.
That's perfect.
It's actually so strong.
Like, what the fuck?
It does so much damage.
No wonder it's legendary.
Oh, I wish I could like buy the palace forever.
Alice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking speed run over to the next rubber band.
Oh, I can't!
Deliver the... what?
No, they're rubber bands!
What?
I can't!
Wait a minute.
I thought it were rubber bands!
What do you mean?
Okay.
Oh.
I'm gonna put the rubber band in.
The very real rubber band!
Nice.
Ah!
No!
Come down and fight Bear!
Oh, holy shit.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bubble.
So I can...
I'm tossing it!
No, please.
Someone.
Someone, please.
Mimi, please!
Where are you?
Mimi!
Ria!
Incoming!
Okay, we need to get rid of this firework.
Yes, I'm slaying!
Okay.
Bringing the pain!
Okay, we got rid of one of them.
Oh, we have...
It's more than one rubber band?
Yes, I'm slaying!
Okay, I'm gonna head over.
I'm heading over to the other rubber band right now.
Wait, is she okay?
She's okay.
She'll be fine.
She'll be so fine.
Oh, God.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Nice.
More toilet paper.
I'm gonna grab a chest.
Open!
Grabbing the dark matter.
Taking this.
God.
I'm gonna grab this.
Guys, it's just to protect the catapult, okay?
How is that?
Like a clown condom?
It's a...
It's to make balloon animals.
Chat, it's a balloon animal.
It's what clowns use to make balloon animals.
That's what it is.
Truly, right?
That's why it's so stretchy and long.
Whoa.
Look how long it...
It makes really big balloon animals.
They can make a dog.
Alright.
We're gonna grab...
Get rid of...
I'm just gonna fucking bone rush it.
It's okay.
I have my dragoons here to distract them.
It's alright.
I don't need to save them.
They're independent.
They're strong, independent goons.
I'm gonna go get them.
Here you go.
Where the fuck is the last rubber band?
The last balloon animal.
There it is.
Oh, no.
It's just noodle arms.
That's fine.
It's okay.
I can just run.
I'm just gonna run.
It's alright.
We're fine!
Ignore everybody!
We have so many animals.
So much toilet paper, we don't need the money!
Oh god, the hockey player is still here.
Get off me!
Ref!
I did it!
Goodbye, dragoons!
I'll always remember you!
Don't worry!
I'll remember everything you've done for me, dragoons!
I did not leave you!
I'll always remember your heart...
Dragoons!
Come back!
Remember me!
Dragoons, take the catapult!
Take the catapult!
Dragoons!
I told you I remember you!
Just take the catapult!
Where are they?
Please!
I'm on my knees begging!
Just take the catapult, Mimi!
Not the dysentery!
There's a catapult right there!
Oh my god!
Ref!
You have Crandon too!
Shit!
But you're not Ginger, so like you're not as good as me.
Oh my god!
There you go.
See?
Look at that.
Was that the best you can do?
Look at that, guys.
See?
I always remember my goons.
Chat.
That was a bad choice for me.
I always remember them.
Never forget.
Never forget what they did.
Where did you get this?
Guys, I...
Guys, I told you.
Never leave a goon behind.
Chat.
Oh my god.
Am I burning people or are they burning people?
I would never.
I would never do something that fucked up.
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of these guys.
Alright.
Nice.
I used the shield just in time.
Come on.
Die!
Why are you guys so fucking tanky?
My shield should go... You're literally standing on napalm!
Here we go.
We're good.
I defeat...
Oh god.
Not the hockey players.
It's okay.
They can't take high ground.
There we go.
They don't know how to climb.
He knows how to climb.
But what if he doesn't know how to climb this platform though?
It's okay.
He doesn't know how to climb this one.
That was a bad choice for me.
Here we go.
That's right.
See?
I told you.
New kid.
Jump down and find Jimmy.
Jimmy?
Where the fuck is Jimmy?
Jimmy's over here.
Jimmy!
That's not Jimmy.
Oh, Jimmy's over here.
There's also chests.
Nice.
More dark matter.
Is that another chest over there?
No, that's just a dead guy.
Pretend dead.
That's just a guy being pretended.
Alright.
We move on.
Woo!
Hello Jimmy.
Alright.
Let's see.
They're all coming.
From behind with your dagger.
Okay.
We're gonna reshuffle.
These cards suck.
Oh!
When using pissed off heal 40...
I feel like I haven't really used the pissed off abilities.
So...
Alright.
I actually forgot which one was pissed off.
Higher one.
Use bullshit...
Wait.
How do I use pissed off?
Do I automatically use my pissed off button?
Enjoy these upgrades new kid.
You've earned them.
Okay.
Missed chests.
That's alright.
We're just gonna move on.
Mimi!
Get over here!
Wait for everyone to upgrade?
Oh yeah.
Mimi has to upgrade.
Oh!
The Q and E!
That's the pissed off stuff.
Looks like you've stumbled right into a marsh walker ambush.
Go get it!
That's just mana.
Oh!
That makes so much more sense now.
I have been using them.
I knew.
I was just testing you guys.
I knew all along.
I just wanted... I was just testing all of you.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Shield.
Alright.
I just gotta...
Just gotta keep my beam up.
God.
This attack is so strong.
I think I'm gonna fucking be a wand user.
I'm gonna be a filthy magic user.
Pew!
Alright.
Now seven more enemies.
Kick all their asses.
Get over here child!
Get over here!
You're not going to first grade!
You're gonna be held back in kindergarten.
Jimmy!
Oh Jimmy.
Get over here.
Oh I cannot use during combat?
God damn it.
Guys we need to kill five more!
Here we go.
Yay!
Alright.
They're all in my fire.
So that's good.
We're taking all the damage.
Shield!
Last guy.
Don't get one guy.
Wait.
Where's the last guy?
Wait a minute.
He's all the way over here?
How did he get over here?
Is he stuck?
What is he doing?
Kid!
You can't hide from me.
You die here.
Alright.
Nice.
Upgrade!
The bubble burns enemies inside it.
Oh my god!
Oh I cannot upgrade it.
I'm too weak.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go.
No child left behind.
Exactly.
Alright.
I'm done with this.
You're taking all the damage!
We did not read that truck.
Haha.
What's a boomerang?
by Zegon He's so relatable!
He's so relatable.
Haha.
True.
Just like me.
For real.
I just wanna get out of here.
So fucking true.
Run!
Just run!
Who cares?
Oh, just keep running!
Okay, guys, we have to actually attack, guys.
Apparently, we actually have to fight.
We can't just run.
God damn it.
We can't just run, chat.
We actually have to kill everybody.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, what's this?
Oh no, we need a cannonball?
Does Cartman actually fight or he's just there being a fat ass?
Oh, fuck.
Can't believe it.
Not my king.
A king does not fight.
A king makes other fight and die for you.
Right, dragoons?
Alright, you guys will fight for me.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Don't worry, we're gonna beat up the sixth grader.
It's alright.
You're not gonna see any, girl.
Puberty is gonna be a fucking miserable time for you.
Alright, yay!
Did we kill everybody?
Where?
That one kid over there?
That's just...
He's just standing there?
Bro!
He's not even... Oh, he's...
Wait, what?
I looked at him and then he pretend died.
Get in the catapult.
We need to get over this wall.
He actually pretend died.
He's like, oh no, it's Doki.
Oh no.
We got him.
We gotta tap out.
Okay, I'm running.
No!
Get me outta here.
Where do we have to go?
Jimmy!
Is he here?
Is he at the theater?
Where the fuck is he?
Find him near City Halla.
Is this City Halla?
Where the fuck are they?
Oh, there's like chests though.
I should actually grab some toilet paper.
I do not have a lot of money.
Wait, is that... The golf kids!
Okay, replenish all zero.
Sacrifice chain lightning to max the level of all your other upgrades.
No way.
I'll take the dark matter.
Yeah, there's no way I'm getting rid of the chain lightning.
That chain lightning is actually so fucking good.
It's been like... It's been like clutching it for me.
Cause I can be like extra lazy.
And I love being extra lazy.
Where the fuck do we go?
Get outta here.
Using a filthy bow.
Pew!
Damn stuff.
Unlimited power.
No!
During bullshit?
Oh yeah.
Guys!
It's me, the real new kid.
Mimi!
Get over here!
I'm... It's okay, I don't need you.
I have real Dragoon number three.
Real Dragoon number three.
How long does it take to res me?
Alright, I need to use shield.
Alright, nice.
Just gonna... You know I'm gonna put a totem pole right inside here.
It should be fine.
Woo!
They burn inside my bubble anyway.
They burn... So I get my pissed off rage at the same time.
So I never lose my piss off cause they're always in my bubble.
We need more forces!
Come on Mark Blackheart!
Where the fuck... Oh no!
Sixth graders!
Did you just hit me?
Get out!
Sixth graders please!
I'm so sorry!
You're okay, you're fine.
Please!
I'm so sorry!
I'm so scared!
Alright.
They have a lot of unresolved issues cause they get bullied by the seventh graders!
Here I come!
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'm gonna go inside.
Oh!
Holy fuck!
God that hurt.
I'm always... That's the secret.
I'm always pissed off.
Alright.
They're still like the...
Alright, oh no.
The girls.
It's the girls.
I'm so scared.
You think they'll like me later?
Alright, nice.
That should be all of them.
Right?
Did I kill everybody?
Alright, upgrade time.
Bubble shield is 40% bigger?
Alright, we're getting that.
It's 50% bigger now.
Nice.
Alright, I'm ready for the battle!
Mimi, get over here!
Wait, Mimi, where are you?
Oh, it's... They went to the goth kids.
Alright.
You gotta upgrade for this and then we're gonna kill Stan Marsh.
We're making up some bullshit rules.
Oh my god, we got cred.
Wait!
You paid $50 too!
Oh my god, we're both stupid!
We pre-ordered before reading the reviews!
That's us!
We're also in the cred gang.
You're no match for my Marsh Walker powers.
So I'm just gonna have my friend Kenny kick your ass.
Kenny?
Alright, you kid, take out Princess Kenny.
Don't let her kiss you or you're totally gonna be pussy whipped.
Butu's cat.
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
Princess Kenny is working with Stan.
No!
That charming son of a bitch is gonna try and stop us with her big ass ass.
She's using her anime powers!
Oh my god!
Somebody stop her!
She's too kawaii!
Oh my god!
Dragon number three, you're in love with Kenny?
I mean, who is it though?
Look at her.
Your anime magic up.
Holy fuck!
I bought him!
Got a fucking simp, man.
Where is it?
No!
They fell down!
Mimi, no!
Oh my god!
What is this?
Holy shit.
Alright.
She can fly?
How the fuck does Stan get Kenny?
That's my Oshii.
Alright, we gotta heal.
It's okay.
I have bubble powers.
He's in the bubble so he's gonna take damage.
This is so much easier than the fucking Kyle fight.
Alright.
I'm good.
I'm heals.
Oh my god, not the bomb.
Not the bomb.
Player two, are you tired or did you just get fucked up?
Alright, here we go.
We're good.
He's one hit!
Princess Kenny's one hit!
Shoot him!
Don't revive Mimi!
Just kill him!
Mimi down.
Kenny, you made my Kamiya Oshii.
That's fucking right, Kenny.
It didn't have to be like this.
Damn it.
We did it.
See?
Look, you're okay.
You're okay, Mimi.
My... Oh my god, you killed my Oshii.
That chest over there?
That is...
Grab that chest.
I'm gonna double check if we're missing anything.
Alright, we should be good.
Lead through the gate.
We're gonna go through.
We're gonna kill you, Stan.
For giving me dysentery.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, it's here?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
Yeah!
We did it!
Look at that.
Most damage given.
We got defeat 10 shield barriers.
Oh my god, we got the Tesla coin.
Where do I go?
Tesla's always there.
We defeated the princess, but Stan still needs an ass kicking.
Good job, new kid.
Princess kitty toy.
Wait, it's not... Oh, okay.
I was gonna say.
Totally cool.
Now load out and get back out there.
Alright.
School is closed and I am so fucking bored.
I can sense a growing darkness deep within your soul.
Join me and we can pierce the veil between the worlds.
Don't be strange and you can't...
Come find me in the fat kid's backyard.
What the fuck?
What is that?
What?
Stan's been kind of an asshole lately.
That's a struggle.
What the fu- Where is she?
Where's the god kid?
We need to pierce the veil.
Can I unlock anything?
No, I haven't.
Oh, I got the whoopee cushion.
Release a drifting void that sucks enemies in and...
I feel like the heals and the fucking bubble is just way too good.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is the god kid?
Oh, there she is!
Okay.
I'm gonna talk to Mr. Hankey first.
Uh...
I am going to...
do...
sprinting...
this.
Okay.
That should be it.
Keep taking in that dark matter and you'll get more powerful than you can imagine.
Wait.
Don't I have missing- What?
There's DLC- I pre-ordered!
What do you mean?
Wait!
There's more?
Okay, I need a...
Okay.
Excuse me?
That's DLC!
What do you mean that's DLC?
I literally have the deluxe version!
I have the deluxe version!
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, it's free!
Guys, it's a free DLC chat.
It's a free DLC.
Okay.
Alright.
At least that's free.
Thank god.
I was like, there's no way!
I literally bought the deluxe version!
What the fuck do you mean?
Like...
I need to have more DLC.
How do I have- need more DLC?
Uh, Zombie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Behold.
The land of Zaron.
Wait.
There's only three chapters?
Oh!
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just play all of it.
It's just three more chapters.
I mean, we're clear- we're so good at this game.
Now I understand!
Now!
Now I understand why- why people were like, I can't believe it's-
We can bypass three chapters- more chapters.
Alright, guys.
It's still open.
The session is still open, guys!
Time to set a battle plan.
You know what?
Okay, kick off.
Okay, you know what?
I'm gonna- I don't need to be number one.
I don't need to be number one, chat.
I am- I know I'm number one in my heart.
I- I know.
I know.
Okay.
Let's see.
Chapter three.
I- I know I'm number one in my heart.
Okay.
That's fine.
What is the avoid spoilers off?
Okay.
Join.
There has to be one game out there.
That's on chapter three.
Where- where are we?
Okay.
Where are we?
What is this stage?
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm leaving.
Sorry.
I- I don't understand.
Okay.
Somewhere in chapter three.
I thought I joined in the middle of- Alright.
Never mind.
I'll be number one.
I guess I'll be number one.
Let's go.
Alright.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back, everybody.
We're gonna finish all the chapters.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
I'm back.
Alright, guys.
Guys, now I understand how this works.
Now I- Now I figured it out.
Evan!
God!
Mike!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
...
Wait.
What?
Oh, okay.
I have to...
I have to pass- Well, I thought I already passed the test of strength.
What do you mean?
I have to do it again?
We already know I'm fucking strong!
Remember, these are designated OP moves that you can only use for a limited time.
Choose carefully.
I missed my- You're gonna actually face us this time, Marswalker?
There's no way you'll be able to get through the test of strength.
Oh, shit!
The napalm!
Nice.
We still have the napalm.
The napalm's so strong.
Alright.
Moon jump- Oh, I just realized I never used my fucking boulder.
Oh, shit.
Um...
Become huge and body slam fools or do area damage.
Oh, wait.
That's so good.
I forgot to use my bullshit cards.
Gigantism!
Awesome!
And some cards to upgrade our magic.
You think you can stop us with that?
Not a chance.
You aren't ready for this.
March giants!
Launched halflings!
Launch?
Why do they still have so many cards?
It's not even hard mode anymore!
Hope you guys are happy with this.
They still have four cards!
Carmen!
Why aren't you making new rules to put us in their practice?
I can only stand in some tests or something to get that act.
This is still four cards!
That means you'll be at his power level.
Or at least immune to dysentery.
Alright.
I need- Hey guys.
I need new kids to move over.
Wow!
I guess everyone's here looking for supplies, huh?
I just want to- I didn't know everybody had the same amount of cards if I put normal mode.
Now I know!
It doesn't matter!
It doesn't matter what fucking mode I'm on!
They'll always have more cards than me!
This is the state that needed his test of strength.
Go talk to his Uncle Jimbo.
He can tell you what to do.
Okay, Uncle Jimbo.
Alright, I'm just gonna grab these fucking- Oh no.
I'm gonna miss this app though.
What's next?
No more ground flaxseed?
I gotta mill it myself?
What the fuck is ground flaxseeds?
What the fuck is that?
Hey guys.
It's so weird seeing them have noses!
It's so weird!
Alright, your turn.
It's the gun store.
What do you mean with guns?
America.
It's so weird that they have fucking noses!
Like, I understand it's 3D, but it's still- It's just- It's not right.
It's not right!
That's me!
I have the funny hat!
Okay, I need to fucking get pissed off right now.
Alright, get over here.
I'm gonna burn you.
It's not the same.
It's not like the electricity.
But it's okay.
I gotta work with what I have.
Which is napalm.
I have more shield.
That's right, unlimited shield!
Unlimited shield if I'm always angry!
Wait, I can just literally skip all these people.
Goodbye.
It's speedrun time!
Oh my god, I'm blinded by what?
Oh!
Guys, I realized why.
Now I realize why I need... I can't just...
Now I realize why I can't just carry everything.
Oh my god, what the fuck is hitting me?
Okay.
There you go.
Don't worry guys!
Protect the leader!
Protect number one!
The real new kid!
Protect me!
Oh!
Please!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's be fine.
We're fine.
Oh shit!
Who keeps hitting me?
They're children!
It should be like a fucking...
Hulk!
Protect the ghoul!
It's okay!
It's just a flesh wound!
Oh, those are not my teammates!
It's okay, body blocked.
I got it.
It's alright.
It doesn't hurt me!
That's creamy as hell.
Get out.
Nice work, kid.
Yeah, here's the next thing I need to... Yes, but he's a tinier child!
My power level should be bigger!
I should have a higher power level!
They're actual...
Actual kids!
Alright, here we go.
We're gonna fucking heal up before we go in.
Grab barrel of NFTs?
What?
Bro...
Not the NFTs.
Is that still fucking relevant?
I thought NFTs are dead!
What was it?
The fucking...
Um...
Bored ape shit?
Did you guys hear, like...
Who was it?
There was a celebrity that recently sold their bored ape and lost, like, $200,000 or some shit.
Oh my god!
I need people.
I need people here right now.
There's, like... Oh, was it Kevin Hart?
Yeah!
Apparently, Kevin Hart lost, like, 200k.
He, like, sold... Oh, not 200k!
Like, $140,000?
Because he bought an NFT for, uh...
He bought an NFT for, like, uh... 200k and then sold it for, like, 60k or something.
Like, sold his bored ape for 60k.
Cause, like, nobody cares about NFTs anymore.
Like...
Or, like, nobody in NA cares about NFTs anymore cause the fucking thing crashed.
Poor, like... Poor, like... Seth Green.
If he...
Seth Green and the fucking cartoon that he wanted to make but he couldn't because a hacker stole his NFT.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm so angry.
I'm so angry!
No!
Number two!
My real dragon, Resmi!
My very real dragon!
I'm gonna get rezzed.
It's okay.
I know you can.
I know you're programmed to rezz.
Nice.
Okay.
We're good.
We got the heals too.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh...
I'm trying my best to speedrun!
It's okay!
We're okay!
We can outrun this!
But yeah.
The reason why, like... Jesus Christ.
Oh no.
No.
I can't outrun this!
Oh!
The tiny kid is too strong!
Alright.
We're good.
We're okay.
Where the fuck is the fireworks guy?
Who the fuck?
How did he fucking, like, slomp me?
Oh god.
That is like a fucking...
That's like a word from the past.
Okay.
Here.
We're good.
We don't have to...
We don't have to worry about the...
But yeah!
For those who don't know...
Seth Green bought...
Oh god.
Not these guys.
Seth Green fucking tried to make an NFT animated.
Half animated, half like...
Oh come on.
Get the fuck away.
Get away from me.
Okay.
Oh no!
Half animated, half live action show about NFTs.
And then the main character is one of his NFTs.
And then his NFT account got hacked.
And then they blackmailed him.
Because they knew he was making a show.
And so he couldn't get his NFT back.
Wait.
No.
He paid like triple... double the price.
Again.
To have his board 8 back.
So he could have his show.
I have a little thing I need you to find.
You know what a chin Pokemon is?
Me neither.
But people will pay good toilet paper for it.
Come get me one.
Oh.
I got chin Pokemon.
No.
I saw the trailer for that show.
And it's fucking terrible.
It's so bad.
It's actually so fucking bad.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
They don't know I'm here.
They don't know I'm a child.
Alright.
Here we go.
I mean.
Yeah.
Oh, man, the Bored Ape fucking- OH GUYS, DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THE FUCKING BORED APE CONVENTION THAT ENDED UP MAKING PEOPLE FUCKING HALF- LIKE BLIND?
The Bored Ape event?
That shit was crazy!
That shit was actually fucking insane, cause they used like, some like, light or whatever?
Okay, so Bored Ape had like a fucking event, and they used like, some blacklight or whatever?
To like, make it cool?
But then they ended up- they bought like the most expensive blacklight that was used to kill pe- like, what was it that was like, radiated- radiation or whatever?
They used UV lights, sorry.
UV lights and stuff.
No, wasn't it like, expensive UV lights that ended up being like, uh- oh, they're cheap?
They bought like, industrial UV lights that ended up like, fucking, um, causing blindness.
That was actually so fucked up.
Oh no, the sixth graders.
Oh no, not the sixth graders.
It was supposed to be used to disinfect things, but they ended up using it for like, a fucking party.
Like an actual party.
Like an actual dance event, which was like, absolutely insane.
That that was a thing.
No!
Yeah, it was used for a fucking concert.
It literally like, caused blindness the next day.
That's actually insane.
Alright, here we go.
Real Dragoon, res me!
Very real Dragoon.
Where's number four?
What the f- is number four stuck?
Okay, there we go.
Alright, it's okay.
My very real Dragoons are helping me.
Did you just hit me?
My very real Dragoons.
Res me!
Don't worry, Naina.
It's actually crazy.
Wait, I know like, the market in NA has actually crashed.
You'll pay for that!
But I don't know if like...
If like, other areas, if it's still like, survive.
If it's still surviving.
Oh yeah, and skin burns too.
That is actually insane.
It's actually insane that that...
That that's real.
That that actually happened.
Oh no.
Not my chin Pokemon.
Chin Pokemon!
You scratch my back, I'll scratch yours.
Yeah.
What the f- am I gonna use the Porta Potty for?
Oh, Mr. Hanky?
Alright.
Mr. Hanky?
I feel...
I feel violated there.
What the f-?
What the f- happened?
Oh my god.
Holy shit, what the f- happened?
There got Venom?
Oh my god.
I think I got Venom there.
I guess I'm immune to dysentery now?
Uh...
Dagger dive does more.
Okay.
The wand drops a Molotov that deals...
Okay, I feel like I just used my wand.
I'm just gonna get the Molotov.
Good luck out there.
Nice.
Uh...
Rapto!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Are you wanting to replay the other South Park RPGs?
I will play Fractured but whole one day.
But I'm not sure when.
I'm just trying to figure out like...
If I should stream that on YouTube.
I played 100% stick of truth and I know the shit that's in there.
So I'm just like, I don't know.
Yeah, if it works it works.
Just a little flat fire, you know.
I'm heading over!
Don't worry!
Oh!
No!
They can't get me!
I have the shield!
My real dragons!
Protect!
No!
I lost the fire because I went into the snow.
Who would have thought?
If you go into the snow, you lose.
You just stop burning.
Who would have thought that could happen?
Did I freeze to death?
You can't keep running into arrows and stay alive.
I'm trying!
Guys, you don't just run into like 20 people and expect to live.
Guys.
A little pro tip for everybody.
A little pro tip.
Don't just run into everything expecting you to live.
Alright, nice.
Oh, god.
Please.
I really need heals right now.
No!
These guys fucking suck!
Fucking... what is the power skill?
Nerf him!
Nerf this man!
Oh, god.
I'm not angry enough.
I need to be angrier.
Okay.
Oh, god.
Oh, my god.
I need a shield too.
Oh, please!
Be angry!
Be angry, new kid!
Alright.
I think we're angry enough now.
We have to be angry.
What the fuck is freezing me?
Oh, it's the snow!
It's the snow that's still making me angry.
I'm calling for balance changes.
Devs!
I need to balance this game!
Oh, god.
Okay, I need to get rid of...
I need to get rid of the fucking fireworks if I want to head anywhere.
Alright, we should be good.
We should be good now.
Where do we go?
Okay.
I'm gonna burn myself here.
But like, how do I get up top?
That's what I do...
No!
Fuck!
I cooled myself down!
Okay.
No stamina again.
Which way do I go?
I'm so confused.
Up top.
Here we go.
Climb.
No!
Come on, come on!
Where's the thing?
Why did me push it down?
Supersize.
Oh, no.
Alright.
Okay.
Apparently there was a ledge.
Apparently... Where am I?
Oh, hey, there's Jimmy right here.
Jimmy right here.
Alright, let's just heal.
I'm gonna stay over here and heal a little bit.
Let's just...
Let's just chill down.
Chill a little bit here.
Alright.
We're gonna figure this out.
I'm not that stupid.
There's a ledge.
Okay.
There's a ledge right here.
We can climb this ledge.
Maybe you'll learn something from the more experienced new kids.
Where...
What is that supposed to mean?
Cartman.
I'm not on fire again?
Where do I climb?
Mr. Man!
What do I do?
I'm still burning.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, I burned.
Wait, this counts!
Oh god.
Yes!
Oh, I hit... No!
What?!
It still doesn't count?
Okay.
My shield could blow up.
What do you mean it climbed on top of it?
Alright.
Okay, we gotta figure this out, guys.
That must hurt.
We gotta figure this out.
My speedrun!
Guys!
What about my speedrun?
I...
Okay.
This is it.
I can climb up.
Where do I go?
Alright.
We got another one.
We got another barrel.
I'm almost there!
Please!
No!
Oh my god, I'm getting bullshit so hard.
This is it!
I'm ready to bullshit!
Oh!
Doki slam!
Alright, nice.
We got it.
Doki is ready to slam!
Okay, we need to like get more of the fire though.
Alright.
Nice.
Get away.
Doki is slamming.
Doki is slamming!
I just need to get there faster!
Okay.
Another one.
Alright.
No!
It's literally right there!
Don't let me die!
Yes!
Okay, we're gonna heal right here though.
Alright.
Nice.
It's okay.
My entire team can kill everybody else.
We have two more!
Alright.
We gotta go this way.
Don't worry.
The speedrun is still there!
The speedrun is still possible!
Woo!
Okay, we gotta get rid of this guy though.
The fucking ice shit is actually pissing me off.
Doki angry.
Doki angry now!
Get out!
Get out, women!
Shielded women!
Get out!
This is a boys only treehouse!
Okay.
Nice.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh god.
No!
My fire!
Ouch!
Alright.
Nice.
Gotta get rid of these two.
Let's get her getting cooties!
And then...
We're gonna press this.
Catapult us above.
And then...
Thank Christ!
One more to the next!
Oh god!
Thank god!
Alright.
Burn.
Burn children.
But pretend burn.
Oh no!
There's six graders!
Oh!
Oh my god!
The reason why all these cartoon shows they never like get...
They never get...
They never age up or go to the next grade is because they want to always have continuity so that people can...
What's the word?
Syndication?
Oh yeah!
So they can always run reruns all the time.
That's the only reason why people never grow up.
It's actually...
I confirm the test has been completed.
You've done well.
Head to the chamber of...
It's actually fucked up.
He made support party new kid.
Great job, Essie!
The network just wants to be able to run reruns all the time.
It's also why like a lot of characters don't go through character development because if they go through character development, running reruns don't make sense.
Oh!
Whoa!
And I watched it!
And I watched it happen.
Alright, let's see.
Common, uncommon.
I'm gonna reshuffle.
I need something that has to do with the wand.
I don't like the dagger.
Or the bubble.
Oh, the bubble is so good!
Yeah, this one's really good.
See ya!
Did you know dragons don't eat paladins?
Apparently they taste awful.
Okay, that one was good, Jimmy.
Will I ever have more than one friend?
You did it!
Dougie did it, you would.
I believed in you.
Alright, now go find Stan and kick his ass!
Okay, we gotta go downstairs.
Sorry he ever challenged me.
Become an honorary marsh?
Wait, I became an honorary marshwalker?
Target sighted!
Oh, it's this one.
This way.
Oh yeah.
Alright, just run!
Just run!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Speedrun!
We don't need toilet paper!
Just go!
Go go go!
Just run.
Okay, we need to heal though.
We can stay here and heal a little bit.
That's okay.
Wait, if you just run, Mr. Man!
Just one of us has to get there!
Oh god, okay, never mind.
I have to get pissed off.
I have to be angry.
Alright.
No, the key!
Not the level 3 elf's lock!
Okay.
Let's get rid of...
Let's get rid of the fireworks, people.
This is how words are won.
Alright.
Nice.
That's right.
Get into my bubba!
Oh yeah?
Who got super size?
Kid Cannon?
It's legal if it's all the kids.
Okay, it's legal if only the kids are doing it.
Okay?
That's why it's legal.
Oh god, I need to get the bubble and then heals too.
The bubbles and heals are so good.
They're so strong.
Alright.
Get over here!
I didn't do the level 3 elf and lock!
Oh, where am I?
Okay, bubble time.
Alright, there's still like two more kids left.
I thought it would feel different.
Alright.
Oh my god!
He has unlimited kids!
When you get rid of fireworks, they have too many kids.
Oh, fun.
Alright, nice.
Child.
Cannon fodder, let's go!
Alright.
That...
No, that's not toilet paper.
Whee!
What the fuck is this?
What trailer is this?
Is this an easter egg?
Oh my god!
I'm watching it backwards.
This is...
A catapult!
Will...
You...
Away...
And...
Fly... the... to...
Fast!
Oh, I could have watched it in the back!
I didn't realize!
No!
I could have watched it here!
My movie!
I didn't understand!
Oh, how?
Oh my god!
You're ruining my movie experience!
Ow!
It's okay.
It moved way too fast.
Alright, nice.
I barely... I barely can see who's in front of me.
What?
How many people are dying?
Ah!
There's a fire!
Two!
I knew it.
I knew that was what's coming out.
We all know Canada's not real.
Because I'm not real.
I'm just an anime girl.
People invented Canada for VTubers.
That's why all...
That's why all VTubers are...
That's why...
That's why a lot of English speaking VTubers are from Canada.
It's not real.
We just say Canada as like a made up country.
It makes sense, doesn't it?
It all makes sense now.
We say Canada because we were like, Oh, where are you from?
We're like Canada.
Bro, what the fuck?
What?
Child!
Child is a bad word not in my Christian South Park stream.
It's all a simulation.
We're still alive.
Bye bye.
What child?
Oh, they're over here.
They're over here.
Beat up these children.
Nope.
Oh no!
That's fine.
I just don't have to move.
I just right click.
Easiest game of my life.
Right click to win.
Fight your way to the rest of downtown.
Alright, we just gotta run.
Don't look back.
Fake new kid.
Just keep running.
We're gonna need to pass through the ice to get to Stan.
Find a cannon bob.
Careful, fellas.
Stan's got cannons too.
We need to find a cannon bob.
Wait, where is the cannon bob?
Dude, your weapons can't break this.
Use the cannons.
Where the fuck is the cannon bob?
Oh, it's over here.
I found one.
I got one.
Break it.
Whoa, nice shot.
Just a few more and you're in.
One more hit and that barrier is going down.
Okay, we need one more.
Fake new kid.
Not the main character new kid.
Where's the other cannon bob?
Wait, where is the other cannon bob?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Oh, it's on me.
See, I got it.
I got it but I can't jump because it's realism.
Because when you're a child, you can't jump and you have a cannon bob because it's not safe.
March walkers to me.
Yes.
Barrier down.
Oh, wait.
Here, he got the other one.
Onward to the playground.
Jimmy!
Stan, ready for your challenge.
Let's get you an upgrade.
Okay.
Uncommon.
Oh, look.
It's 20%.
Yes.
Do I have enough to upgrade?
I do.
Okay.
This is the OP one.
Ah, yes.
A fine upgrade.
Alright.
Nice.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Alright.
Let's go.
New
kid.
You're dead.
Ha!
Oh, no.
16 damage.
16 damage?
Yeah.
Since I passed the test of strength, your 10 plus act is largely ineffective now.
Wait a minute.
The new kid has the secret power too?
So then I'm not super OP anymore?
Does that mean Cartman wins?
Not exactly.
Why don't you just use the class 10 combat base that you built?
You have a dragon for Christ's sake.
Oh, he has a dragon?
Okay, new kids.
Prepare to die.
How the fuck are we gonna hit Stan all the way up there?
Yeah.
How the fuck does he get a dragon?
There's a cannon.
Put me in, boss.
Wait.
I'm boss.
Children, put me in.
Wait, where the fuck is the other cannon?
Oh my god, there's more.
We're gonna do it.
I got the other cannon.
It's okay.
But how do I get the cannonball up top?
Oh, there it is.
There's a rap.
The only way to get back to defenses is with the cannon.
Look around for some cannonballs.
But how do I put it in?
Yeah, let him fucking have it.
How did you get up there?
How does Mr. King do that?
How do men do it?
Number two!
I have a cannonball right here!
What do I do?
How did you get up?
I'm gonna watch you.
How did you do it?
Oh, there's a rap.
There's a rap.
I figured it out, guys.
There was a rap.
Look at this place.
Guys, we did it.
God, we're so smart.
We're so fucking smart.
Who would have thought there was a rap all along?
It was right here.
You won't win, new kid.
I was a little bit directionally challenged.
Get over here, Stan.
I completed the quest.
I used the dark matter.
I'm not new.
Maybe I wasn't using enough.
Oh, God, no.
Oh, no.
Please get that thing away from me.
Okay, that kinda hurt.
Get that thing away.
No!
Get away from me!
You can't hide from my action.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
There's so much fire going on.
I told you, man.
Oh, God.
Be angry.
I have to be angry.
Get in my bubble.
Get in the flames!
Oh, my God.
Where are you?
He's just whacking me.
Where is he?
Oh, God.
I need to get the bubble in.
Take that.
That's right.
The closer you get to me, the more damage you're gonna get.
You won't beat me.
I won't.
Stan!
Everyone's going crazy fighting each other for toilet paper.
But I've been finding these treasure chests filled with it all over the place.
People are just leaving them in hidden but easily findable locations.
Can you believe that?
I also beat up Stach and took his toilet paper, too.
We're gonna be rich, Stan!
Dad, not now.
I have to defeat my enemies.
Enemies?
Well, wait.
So if you lose, do they get to take our toilet paper?
I guess.
Yeah, those are the rules.
Oh, shit.
No, they can't have our toilet paper.
Wait, but he's an adult!
You're gonna join in the middle of a Class 10 base siege?
Well, uh, you know what?
Sure.
What?
Run!
I'm cutting you down!
Oh my god!
He fucked up my- Oh my god!
I just- Oh!
Where am I?
I turned into a PNG because of Randy!
I'll tell tales of your bravery!
Like, what the fu-
That's fucked up, man!
Randy, that's fucked up!
Okay.
How did he die?
Oh my god!
Bro!
Where the fuck- Okay, he's one hit!
Guys, let me kill Steel!
Let me kill- Yeah, I killed Steel.
He's a warrior!
Dad!
Please, do whatever you want, but Stan!
Don't hurt the toilet paper!
I was gonna be rich!
Stoooch!
I can't believe I can't pause an online game.
Thank you guys for not letting me die.
Guys, I can't believe it!
I can't- I still managed to pause an online game.
Let's go!
That's a ton of dark matter!
A real impressive load!
Look at us go!
We're so good!
No problem.
I play game in Honorary's Marsh Walker!
Let's go.
Pause the internet!
Pause!
Why can't you just play by the same rules as everyone else?
Because my version of the rules actually work!
The way you guys do it, it doesn't even make any sense!
You don't even know what power-ups go with what abilities!
And that's why you turned into a total dick?
Oh, I'm a dick because I stood up for what I believe in.
Upgrades shouldn't be awarded every level!
It's confusing!
Well, we beat you, Stan!
Wait, what?
But that makes sense!
Yeah, so can you please stop this winter spell before more people get hurt?
Yeah, what are you talking about?
Come on, Stan!
We know this snowstorm isn't natural!
Somebody use magic!
Do you really think I would purposely start a storm that's killing people and shutting down the whole town?
The way you've been acting lately?
Yes!
Why did you turn against everybody and get all aggro?
I don't know, okay?
He's going through things.
I guess...
Ever since I got that dark matter stuff from Mr. Hanky...
It's Mr. Hanky!
What did you say?
Mr. Hanky!
...from Mr. Hanky?
The Christmas Pooh?
He's the secret villain!
That could be it.
What could it be?
Remember?
Mr. Hanky was kicked out of town!
By the entire town!
Yeah, that's why I was surprised Mr. Hanky's back.
He got phased out.
Mr. Hanky kept getting wasted and tweeting things.
Oh, come on!
No!
Oh no, not that episode!
If anyone would want to hurt this town...
Whoa!
How could you accept dark gifts from Mr. Hanky and not tell anyone, Stan?
And this is why I'm scared of playing the second game on YouTube.
Who does that?
I remember that episode.
I guess we have to find Mr. Hanky and put a stop to him.
By Zaron's balls, we'll find him and destroy his dark powers.
And then we can stop this horrible winter storm!
And then all the stores can finally open again.
Yeah.
And people stop fighting over toilet paper and get back to work!
Right!
Yeah!
And we can all get back to going to school!
What?
No!
Karma's gonna be the other secret villain.
Chapter 4 is gonna be...
Whoa!
I don't think this is gonna end well, Ned.
No shit.
What do you want guns for?
Excuse me!
Hot cocoa anyone?
Free delicious hot cocoa!
Everyone's favorite winter tan treat!
I know you're all tired and hungry and cold.
How about something to get you through the night?
Father Maxie, would you like some hot cocoa?
Uh, sure!
I guess I can have a little hot cocoa before the world ends.
It's pretty cold.
I'll take some hot cocoa.
Does it have dark matter?
Oh, it has dark matter!
We're gonna fight adults?
It's not for children anymore.
I'm never going back to school.
And you'll never have to, Eric.
Sweet.
No!
I sense great dark matter within you.
That's not dark matter.
Oh my god.
Guys!
Guys, I think this is a medical concern now.
I think this is a medical concern now.
There's not even a school to go back to?
It's probably buried in like 50 feet of snow.
Guys.
I think this is a medical concern now.
I don't think...
Oh no.
Constructed mechanical monstrosity that fires snowballs for you.
I still feel the shield is really good.
I feel like I'm still gonna run shield and heals.
Oh, that's it!
Okay, that's the level 10.
That's the level 10 battle axe.
Okay.
And then...
And then... alright.
And then press while jumping... woah!
That's fucking crazy!
Alright, Dark Matter time.
Let's see.
You deal 20% damage?
Fuck yeah!
Oh, I do not have a lot.
Ice Skater?
Oh!
Alright.
I don't know about that.
I don't know.
I'm worried about this Dark Matter thing now.
Not this Dark Matter!
Alright, let's see.
Anton.
Alright.
Here we go.
Are you ready?
Wait!
Where's... wait!
No!
Who's gonna carry me?
Why are they always gone when I need them the most?
Sammy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
TLDR, if you're pooping Dark Matter, please see a doctor.
If your poop starts talking back to you, there might be something wrong with your brain.
Wait,
does that mean Mr. Hankey doesn't get bullshit?
Oh, God!
Fucking flashbang out of nowhere.
Alright.
The wand is, but will set you on fire over time.
You know what?
That's a risk I'm gonna take.
Bein' on fire for a little bit wouldn't be that bad, right?
I'm gonna go with the...
This time I'll actually use this bullshit.
He is the bullshit.
And then this snow day will finally be over and we can all go back to Scoot.
Haha!
Surprise!
The plot twist!
God damn it, Carmen, what are you doing?
I'm finally gonna live the life I've always dreamt of, Cam!
A life with no skin!
Mr. Hankey is ruining South Park.
We can't keep living like this.
Don't worry, you won't be living much longer anyways.
Mr. Hankey has given me the power of Dark Magic.
And I'm gonna use it to destroy you guys!
Wait, but then that means he gets like...
15 cards!
He can do the spells... he can do the...
Fan spells!
What a twist.
Wait...
Wait, but like who the fuck is in his army?
These DOLTS!
Oh my god.
That's not fair!
You got adults to play pretend with?
This is not pretending.
This is not a game anymore.
He got adults involved.
The adults are gonna beat up children!
That's a lawsuit!
Make your way through the backyards.
Oh no.
Oh no, the Venom army.
Bro!
What fucking slap from an adult?
What?
Oh god.
Thank god it's just a kid.
Guys, it's okay.
It's just a child.
It's okay, guys.
Oh no, there's no napalm.
This is so much more difficult without napalm now.
It's actually more difficult.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Okay.
We got it.
Oh no!
We got it here!
Is it because I'm also on fire?
That I'm taking... no, it can't be.
No, that can't be it.
Okay, we gotta get rid of the children.
I got the fucking barrier.
They're so tanky!
We're... oh!
They're so fucking... what the hell?
Why are they so strong?
What?
Holy shit!
They're actually so fucking strong.
It's actually crazy.
Okay.
Even if I do like 50% more damage.
They do so much.
Okay.
Fine.
We're gonna stay here for now.
We're gonna heal forever.
The difficulty spike.
Yeah, I'm healing myself.
I don't care about the teammates here.
Oh no.
Alright.
Heals.
I'm only using the heals for myself.
Oh, come on.
Alright.
We're good.
We just have to...
Have to head up.
Get up here!
Get over here, children!
Don't start here yet so I can have an excuse to beat you up!
Alright, I hope Jimmy has the napalm.
That's like my only hope right now.
Where do I go?
Did I kill everybody yet?
No, they're over there.
Alright.
Heal us.
This is the trick.
If I start healing next to it, I don't take fire.
Technically, my heals negate the fire damage that I took.
Like, look at this damage I'm doing!
It's so sad!
It's actually so sad!
Children!
Please!
This dark matter is not healthy!
Alright, nice.
Did we defeat everybody?
Is that everybody?
Oh my god, he's all the way over there?!
Guys, my very real dragoons.
Okay, that's it.
This is it.
I'm gonna use my melee.
My level 10 axe.
Wait.
Guys, I have a feeling... Oh my god.
Guys, I just... There's a possibility...
There's a possibility...
That my level 10 axe is really fucking strong.
I don't know.
It's just a theory.
It's just a theory that my axe could be really fucking strong.
But I'm not sure yet.
It's just a game theory though.
It's just a game theory.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, this fucking tree though.
Okay.
Oh!
Kids!
Dragoons!
Protect the queen!
Okay.
We just gotta kill this... the tree.
Oh no!
Okay, nice.
Too bad the barrier does not fucking work.
It's gonna work against the melee.
I'm just gonna burn it for now.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Gotta get rid of the baby tree.
Baby tree, goodbye.
Okay, and then... SLAM!
There we go.
Nice.
That should be everybody, right?
No!
One more!
SLAM!
Okay.
There we go.
We're good.
Level 10 axe, baby.
Axe is strong.
Goes back to fire.
Cause it's like gun!
It's almost like gun!
I can't stop myself!
Gough kid!
Uhhhh...
Raise the rarity of the fire elemental card.
70% additional damage.
Fuck.
Okay, 70%.
I need more strength.
I'm like... I feel so weak.
I feel so fucking weak right now.
We need this.
Where do I go?
This way?
Careful, new kid.
God matter makes these enemies stronger than anything you've fought before.
Oh, that's why they're so fucking strong.
Okay, that makes sense now.
Oh no.
It's okay.
I was like, no wonder they hit so hard.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay.
We're good.
We're good now.
I do 70% more damage.
Golly, player one.
That's it, new kid.
Just jump into the snow if you have any skills.
That's alright.
I have heals right next to me.
They can't aim.
Oh shit!
It's okay.
I can heal again.
That's right.
Oh, okay.
Barrier.
Alright, there we go.
I can heal again!
That's right!
I'll just stand here and take everything!
Player one, you okay now?
Yeah, I'm pretty alright.
Wait, did I defeat everybody?
Then they're all dead.
Yeah, they are.
Alright, let me just heal.
More fire.
Okay, I need to heal myself so I can keep burning people.
Treasure!
Is that upgraded?
80%!
Alright, now I'm definitely stronger than May.
Oh fuck, where did you come from?
Where are my friends?
Oh, there you go.
My real friends.
Okay, we gotta burn him.
Alright, that's right.
Never have to use melee ever again.
Yeah!
That's really lucky though that I got like the...
That I got the fucking 80%.
Yeah!
I can just stand in front of you.
Dodge?
What's that?
No need to dodge.
Real gamer hours.
Real gamer hours right here.
There you go, we did it.
Yay!
Can I unlock it?
Where?
They're all dead.
Where are the enemies?
Avelion, thank you for 10 gift ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Where the fuck are they?
Jimmy?
Is Jimmy here?
Is it Jimmy?
Where the fuck are the enemies?
Bro, this song is hardcore though, not gonna lie.
This song is like so fucking hardcore for the situation I'm in.
Are you... what?
Guys, mixed reviews.
But I wanna know how the story ends!
The things I do for self-park.
Alright.
I mean, it's like five chapters, you know?
I might as well.
It's five chapters.
We're already past the two hours mark.
We're already past the two hours mark, so we might as well try to see how the story ends.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, this way.
Alright.
Nice.
Here we go.
You think you're hot shit for getting through some of my forces?
Guess what?
I got plenty more where that came from, you kids!
Oh my god, now I actually have to dodge!
No!
There's too many children!
Oh, what's the bullshit this time?
Projectile Hellstorm.
This is as far as you go!
Bullshit card in play!
All projectiles are multiplied!
Woah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's okay.
We gotta kill all the bow and arrow kids.
It's alright.
I see you.
It's okay.
Dodge.
Oh, wait.
Shield!
Oh!
Wait, you're not in bow and arrow!
Alright.
That's okay.
My very real dragoons fell down so they can't res me.
Oh, I'm back!
I'm back!
Oh my god!
Alright, there you go.
I'm just gonna stay here.
It's fine.
I'm gonna stay here.
Use my heals.
Get a little angie.
There you go.
Jesus Christ, these children.
These children need a fucking...
These children need to get checked to see if they're on any steroids.
Holy fuck.
What is this dark matter that makes this...
What's making them so strong?
I don't understand.
Like, what's making them so strong?
Dark matter should not...
You should be like in the bathroom right now.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, god.
Please.
Get her away from me.
Get her off me.
Get her off me!
Nice.
We did it.
We got the dark matter.
Matter.
Jimmy, please.
Jimmy, where are you?
Jimmy?
Jimmy, do you have napalm?
No!
Okay, we need napalm.
Reshuffle.
Beefcake?
Increases your max- Okay, no, not that.
The bubble shield heals 2% health to all inside of it.
What about me?
I want you to heal me!
What about me though?
We'll do Beefcake.
Oh my god, he doesn't have napalm!
But what about me?
I don't care about my allies!
It just says plus 2 for my allies!
It doesn't even say plus 2.
That's me!
Alright, we'll grab some toilet paper.
That's okay, I got Beefcake.
You're in the team.
There is no- But it said allies!
I don't know, I don't trust it.
Wait, there's necromancers?
Oh!
That's a forbidden spell!
Oh, you gotta kill those necromancers dude, or they'll just keep reviving the guys that you knocked out!
Which one?
Oh!
Friends!
Real dragoons help!
Player 1, they almost had you dude!
It's okay, we're okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Alright, we gotta kill them.
Why do I only have 2 real dragoons?
It shouldn't matter!
What?
Oh god.
Okay, here we go.
We got him.
Oh my god, get over here.
Get over here.
Get over here, mage necromancer.
You're breaking the rules!
The fairy- Oh, the good part of fair- All parents never teach you anything!
Alright, we got rid of one of them.
Defeat all enemies.
Always listen to the rules!
Alright, nice.
Wait, is that also a necromancer?
Yeah, he is.
Don't worry, spin to win.
Holy shit, I should have been fucking spinning since the beginning.
Alright.
Up we go.
E.
We got E.
There has to be like- We have to like fight the adults soon, I feel like.
Okay.
Alright, see necromancer.
Don't worry.
I'm spinning!
Spin!
I'm gonna keep spinning!
No!
My spin!
Oh, not you.
Not you!
Fuck this.
I'm gonna do it.
I've had enough.
Get over here.
I can't fucking see but get over here!
Wait, is that the necromancer?
No, the necromancer is dead.
Alright, I'm gonna head over.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here, archers.
That's fucking right.
Spin to win.
You can't fucking run away from me.
You're- You're projectile.
Alright, as long as the necromancer is dead, so I don't have to worry about them reviving him.
Alright.
Man, I should've been spinning this entire time.
Whoo!
Alright, heals.
Alright, if you get close, I'm gonna spin!
If you get close to me, I'm gonna spin!
Oh, shit!
Alright.
I'm gonna spin!
Don't you dare!
Oh!
Woah!
I'm sure someone will pick you up any time now!
Oh, no!
NPC number four!
I can't... no!
I have to do that all over!
Are you kidding me?
Oh no!
No way!
No fucking way!
Number four dragoon, how could you?
How could you, number four dragoon?
I can't believe it!
Number four goooood!
There has to be somebody on chapter four!
There has to be!
Okay.
Okay, wait.
There has to be.
There has...
There has to be somebody in chapter four!
Someone out there must still be...
... still be playing!
Somewhere out there!
Wait, no!
Fuck no, not this chapter!
Fuck I clicked any!
I clicked any!
No!
Where am I?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm leaving you.
I clicked the wrong one.
I chose any chapter.
There has to be somebody in chapter four.
There has to be!
Alright.
Let's see.
Desire chapter.
Chapter four.
You must be somewhere out there!
Bye, Lakeisha.
I know you're out there.
I can't be the only one on chapter four.
Where am I?
Hello!
Where is this?
What?
Where... Where is this?
Wait a minute.
I did it!
Yay!
You make me kick the cunt!
Alright.
I'm leaving.
I'm sorry.
I don't understand.
I know I'm so good.
I got someone who was like, Colorado?
Alright.
We're going to do spoilers off.
Join game.
Avoid spoilers off.
Okay.
Chapter.
Because then I don't get any cutscenes.
I think by clicking that, I don't get any cutscenes.
Okay.
I'm back.
I want to see the cutscenes for real this time.
What?
No!
You're the only one on chapter four.
You cannot be the only one.
You can't...
There's no way.
How are you the only guy in chapter four?
He's the same person.
There's no way.
There's no way he's the only person in chapter four.
Chapter 4!
The only person on there.
Okay.
Alright.
Chapter 4.
Has to be a different guy at that point.
The only other Canadian.
They have to be so confused.
Oh my god!
We did it!
Guys!
Friends!
Hello.
I am here to invade your session.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
I knew it!
I knew I'll find real people.
We did it guys!
Let's go!
Look at that.
Real people.
I knew it.
I found friends.
Guys.
I did it.
There's no way these guys can fuck it up.
There's no way.
Let's go.
Guys!
I know where to go guys.
It's this way.
It's this way guys.
Don't worry guys.
Come on!
Get over here!
Guys!
Get over here guys!
Don't worry.
I'm playing.
Guys.
I know it says the number 3.
But it's because I decided to be generous today.
Look at that.
Defeat all the enemies.
Don't worry guys.
Oh my god!
We're actually...
We're actually in an area that I can figure out.
Oh!
I have the lightning!
Wait!
They like pick...
I have the chain lightning shit!
Oh shit!
That's so good!
I love the chain lightning.
If we just need the napalm then we're fine.
Oh no!
We actually have the rez.
It's okay.
The other players can rez.
I'm the DPS.
Unlimited power.
Oh no!
I'm almost dead.
Almost unlimited power.
Ew.
We found the area though.
It's alright.
Somebody would rez him, right?
Like somebody would eventually rez that man, right?
We're good.
What the fuck?
Who did that?
Who the fuck is doing that?
Who is doing that?
I can't believe we found people.
Real people.
Oh!
I got better chain lightning.
Alright.
I guess we should revive him.
Who did that?
Who's doing that?
Okay.
We gotta get rid of these guys.
Oh look!
He's back to normal.
Oh my god.
I'm so paranoid.
Who's doing that?
I'm so fucking paranoid right now.
Wait.
What?
Why are the...
Why are the dead...
Wait.
The dead can do that?
What?
Wait.
How come they didn't do that when I was playing?
Okay.
I know that one was you.
I know that one was you number four.
Yeah.
But why didn't they do that when I was playing the game?
Oh god.
Please.
How do you turn it off?
Don't even bother resisting me you guys.
You're playing by my rules now.
Oh it's one of the cards?
Oh.
That's a card?
But why?
What does that even do as a card?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe somebody played far enough to know that that's a card.
Like somebody has like...
Has enough knowledge of the Snowballs...
The Snow Day game to know that's a fucking card.
How much did you guys play to know that?
That's a good question.
Makes you go faster.
Alright.
We gotta get the chain here.
Bro this host keeps dying.
I'm the new captain now.
Don't rez him!
Let him learn!
Let me be the new player one!
Alright we have to feed all of these guys.
How many someone's willing to play that far?
That's why I'm here.
I'm playing it this far so you guys don't have to.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Nice.
We killed everybody.
We gotta go.
This way.
Jimmy!
Uhhhhhh... Molotov cocktail.
Drops a Molotov.
Is it worth it?
Uhhhhhh...
That's 68.
Wait!
No!
The spin!
The legendary spin!
Alright we got it.
Let's go.
I'm ready.
Wheeeeeee!
I'm gonna spin.
Spin to win.
Okay.
Entering Main Street.
Alright.
This is the part where I died.
Hahaha.
I just got...
Yeah!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Well this game has mixed reviews and I sort of know why...
I can...
I sort of know why this game has mixed reviews.
Like...
It's...
It's very obvious why.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Why didn't I...
Why didn't I do any damage to him?
Oh there we go.
That was so weird.
I didn't do any damage just then.
Okay.
I'm gonna heal a little bit.
The reviews were not wrong.
That's for sure.
Like...
I know why it's mixed reviews.
Phew.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm spinning.
At least I can hold the charge up when I'm moving.
Just screw those guys and go home!
Alright.
We're going!
Push up!
Push forward!
I need to go to the place where I die!
Keep pushing!
Oh god.
There's the...
Necromancer here.
Oh it's cause of the shield!
Oh!
I understand!
I get it now.
There was a shield.
Oh!
I'm gonna die!
It must be a card or something.
Oh no.
No!
Woo!
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm spinning.
I'm okay guys.
I need to press an E here though.
Guys!
Someone E!
You're down again?
Spin!
Okay.
E.
We need all the E's!
Put all the heals!
Right here in the center!
Double the heals!
Wait what?
All data down?
We need double the heals!
Speedrun!
Wait what the fuck?
Okay.
We're okay.
Oh this is good.
This is like...
No.
Not the bullshit.
Wait what's that?
How dare you oppose the Grand Wizard?
What's that?
What does that do?
What...
What do I have?
I don't know!
This is not my session!
Oh I'm taking damage but I don't know what I'm doing!
What is it?
I wanna know what my bullshit does.
Oh I can run forever!
I can run forever!
Woah woah woah woah woah!
Heal time!
Woo!
No!
My first death!
It's just like last game!
Oh oh!
Number two!
Number two I'm so important!
Number four!
I'm so important!
You know it!
It's alright.
Spin!
Just don't res number one!
We gotta establish a hierarchy here.
Okay.
Woo!
Nice I got a heal.
It's alright we're good.
We're good.
And then last guy!
Woo!
What the fuck?
Oh it's the stealth guy!
Jimmy!
Guys can you kill the last guy?
Guys I need to talk to Jimmy!
There's one more guy!
Come on there's just one more!
You guys got this!
I'm number one now!
Oh nice!
Oh but what last?
Two percent!
Oh!
You need two seconds more when you deal... and you deal very pers... oh wait that's so good!
Nice!
I'll take that.
Yay!
Number one get over here!
God this is... guys... guys this is why we have to kill number one.
Like they're holding us back.
He's holding us back and you can see it.
Look at him.
He doesn't even have cred.
Come on.
Look at me.
Look at you!
You have cred!
I have cred!
Hahaha!
They're holding us back and you know it.
You know it.
They are the host.
Yeah but that's only their job.
Being the host doesn't make you special.
It's... you have to earn number one.
Wait where do we go?
Survive all the waves.
Where are the waves?
Oh there they are.
There are the waves.
Don't worry I'm heading back.
I'm heading over.
Spin!
Don't worry.
The moment I keep spinning...
Spin!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
This is such an OP attack.
This is actually so OP.
Holy shit.
I put shields and then I spin.
Spin!
Eh.
Don't worry.
I'm going to get you.
Spin!
Oh shit.
Oh my god that's a lot of people.
Woo!
You're getting carried.
You're all getting carried.
You're getting carried by a real gamer.
I played on hard difficulty.
This is baby.
This is baby level.
Okay gotta get the bubble though.
Okay.
Spin!
Let it rip.
It's like Beyblade all over again.
Oh god please!
Last guy!
Last one!
Wait no.
Wait is that really?
Is there more?
Where's the la- oh over there.
Guys on me!
On me!
You can't hear me but on me!
Beyblade.
It's time to Beyblade.
We have what?
Please get me out of here.
I'm going to get you.
We just have- we have two more chapters left.
We're so close.
We're so close to finishing this game.
Spin.
Alright now I'll actually zap because I actually don't know where they are.
I lost track of people.
They're going way too fast.
I can't be bothered to chase after them.
I can't be bothered to chase after this fucker.
Alright.
It's all the fucking stealth elves.
Bro you're not cool!
Alright.
We gotta help.
We gotta help these two.
Alright.
It's time!
For my secret weapon!
Woooooo!
This is like babies of urban times.
I think.
I think I'm gonna die.
All I'm gonna say.
Never go out of the formula.
Let it rip.
Oh god no.
Not the sixth graders.
It's okay.
They can't jump up here so I'm fine.
See?
They- oh!
What?
You're not even the sixth grader!
I'm stunned forever!
I'm- oh god.
Oh!
I- I got poisoned.
I definitely got poisoned.
I'm so sorry.
Alright.
Nice.
It's fine.
We got double heals.
Okay.
We gotta get rid of the sixth graders here.
Ow!
Wait!
He's like shooting his own people!
I don't need heals.
Okay maybe I do.
Maybe- maybe I do need heals.
Where the fuck is the last guy?
Oh!
Did we survive it?
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
Oh!
We survived!
We made it!
Alright.
Let's see.
Rubber bubble.
It deals 8 damage to the attacker.
Do I risk it?
I'm gonna risk it.
I might have napalm.
God damn it.
Wait.
I can- I can risk it again.
Come on.
I can do this.
Come on Jimmy.
Don't fuck with me Jimmy.
I guess I'll think of the team.
I guess- I guess I'll think of the team.
There's Eric.
I lost the gotcha.
I did.
Alright Eric.
We're gonna catch you.
You're ruining the game.
You're the one ruining the game.
What the fuck do you mean?
You're the one that's fucking up the game.
There's rules to this.
I'm skipping everybody.
Player one.
You okay now?
I'm gonna head over.
I went the wrong way.
Why did you guys follow me?
It was actually this way.
It's okay.
Find the traitor.
That's Carmen.
We already know who the traitor is.
It's okay.
There you go.
And I- three knows what's up.
I still don't know what this does.
What is this doing to me?
What the fuck does this do to me?
Oh come on!
We had to defeat them anyway?
This is fucked up.
We had- It didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
It didn't fucking matter.
We had to kill them anyway.
Okay.
See ya.
Oh I do heal!
I am an ally!
I'm ally!
Okay, don't worry.
I have spin.
Speeeeeeeen.
I can kill like three at the same time, which is great.
This is so... this is so good for me.
Okay, Q.
Q!
Oh god, please stop.
Please stop!
Alright.
Can we do it?
No, there's one guy left.
Stop!
I know it's one of you guys!
I know it's one of you.
Stop!
I swear to god, please!
Now you're gonna get it, new kid.
Stop!
Alright, we gotta get Karmic now.
I'm a new kid trying to ruin my snow day time!
One minute, poopsiekins.
I just need to dab on a little more Christmas magic.
Oh no.
Not the Christmas magic.
Not the adults!
Oh!
Holy shit!
Bro!
This is serious.
This is actually serious.
It's okay, I can spin.
This is why you get the Doki Carry.
Bam!
Instant.
Wait, we did it!
Wait, we killed him!
So fucking easy.
I hate... I... I don't understand!
I don't understand why, like, this host has this fucking lobby.
Bro, the adults can actually kill you!
Alright, where do we go?
Oh, we have to go... actually...
Oh my gosh, there's more adults?
There's more adults?
Oh!
That doll's gonna break my back!
Alright, here we go.
They're gonna start grounding me!
Woop!
Where are you?
Oh god.
Bro, she's like one!
Fucking kill stealer!
Okay, I'm gonna grab the arrows.
Alright, fuck this.
I'm using it.
I'm gonna fucking fly.
Oh, what?
Come on!
I'm trying to fucking...
I'm trying to fucking spin!
There we go.
Nice.
Is that everybody?
Who else is left?
I can fly forever now.
I almost got paid.
Bro!
Bro, it's no joke!
She can actually bait me!
Bro, I'm a child!
You fucking...
Press my head!
You pressed the wrong spot in my head, I fucking die!
That shit is serious!
Oh, there's a Carven!
There's Carven!
There's Carven right over here!
Holy shit, he has venom powers!
Shit.
Oh!
Where is he?
Where's the fucking Carven?
Where the fuck is Carven?
No!
It's this again!
Alright, get out of your fucking force field.
Get out of your fucking force field!
Get over here!
Get over here, you fucking archer!
Nice.
Oh my god, I need you guys to group up more.
I'm wasting my attack on one person.
I really need you guys to group up more.
Shit.
Oh, thank god.
There you go.
That's what I like.
Three for one special.
See, guys?
I'm helpful.
I don't know how I always get tricked into...
I always know that like, every time Carven runs, it means he has to...
It means like I have to defeat all the enemies, but every time it gets me...
Every time I forgot about that and I just run into like five different enemies.
Five different people.
Alright.
Wait, there he is!
Oh, he was a fucking clone!
I'm so OP right now.
Okay, we need to go over here.
Are you good?
It's Carven time.
Finally!
Carven, get over here!
Take me to the next area!
What the fuck?
Bro, it's not fair.
I'm so stupid.
I didn't know that it was a clone.
Okay.
It's fine.
One and two!
One and two can handle these guys!
We run so one and two can handle the rest of the people.
Alright.
Get over here.
We have to defeat the sniper.
Alright.
Up we go!
Jimmy!
No!
Who's still alive?
Four!
Go and get them!
I'm gonna wait at Jimmy's place.
I believe in you four!
Go do your thing!
I'll be right here!
Bro, what the fuck?
Come on!
It's one guy!
I only got two and I was just like, whatever.
Look, I already did my job.
Okay?
Did you not see me kill the three adults?
Come on!
There's still two more?
It's okay.
They'll be fine.
Look!
I can't keep doing everything!
Chat!
I'm not gonna do everything!
Let's just...
Yeah.
Let's go two.
You know what I mean, two.
Let's go!
What the fuck is one doing?
Bro, can one aim?
No!
I think one is like, not doing so well.
Yeah!
Oh, I got the zombie shuffle dance.
What is this?
The moving... I like how this is called the moving grooving when it's the Snoopy dance.
They'll be fine.
I'm not gonna get kicked!
They know... They know that I am the carry.
They won't kick me out because I'm the carry.
Ah, deploy a Molotov.
I want to see if I can get legendary.
God damn it!
Oh, okay.
Point percent bigger.
That's always good.
Alright, I'm ready.
Let's go.
Let's go two.
Come on.
Nice.
I got big, Bubba.
Big.
Hey, the Car... There is more?
Carmen, please!
I know!
This is when you know this is not realistic because Carmen would never run this far.
This is not realistic.
Carmen would never be up that mountain.
He'd be like... It would have been done after like the first two areas.
Oh, shit!
How dare you oppose the Grand Wizard?
The enemy played a bullshit card.
It's just because he really doesn't want to go.
He really doesn't want to go to school.
Unrealistic.
Carmen would never walk so far.
What is this?
Oh, God.
What the fuck?
Get over here.
You're nearly one.
My axe is not long enough.
He fucking went up the fucking roof.
All that for the roof?
Alright.
Where the fuck... Okay.
Get out.
Oh, my God.
I'm so blocked.
What?
Bro!
Help!
I'm so blocked!
Bro!
This is not fair!
Oh, my God!
I'm okay!
Oh, he's gone!
He's gone!
He can't hurt me no more.
He can't... He can't hurt me anymore.
Holy shit!
I got fucking soft blocked so hard.
You went down that road.
Regretting it, aren't you?
They always do.
Alright.
Hey, Goff.
Hey, Goff kid.
Raise the level of all your upgrade cards.
Raise the rarity of the Chain Lightning card.
I'm gonna raise the level.
That's powerful.
So I can have bigger spins.
Thank your science for this moment of rest, new kid.
Alright.
It's time.
It's time, guys.
What is this?
Oh, this is it.
This is it.
It's time to kill Cartman.
Come on.
You must have known you were disposable.
And lucky for me, Mr. Hankey gave me some of his power.
Oh, no, Cartman.
No, Cartman.
That's not good for you.
Oh, no.
You don't want Mr. Hankey to attack the real Cartman.
Get him, giant meat!
Scream, you cat!
Oh, God.
Force Field!
I'm trying to head towards him!
Wait, he gets to have his Force Field too?
What the fuck?
Oh, no.
He doesn't get his Force Field.
That's like... that's just his...
Aww, that's just his projectile thing.
Oh, God.
How is he so strong?
Who let him have the illegal spells?
Where did he go?
Oh, my God.
He's over there.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm spinning.
He doesn't get sucked up into my fucking spells.
Oh, no.
Someone revive him!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
I got the Q.
Where is he?
Please.
Where's the real wizard he saves as he's using the Force Fields?
Where is he?
I'm fucking using those.
Bro, he doesn't get sucked up into my Force Field.
So that's not fair.
Oh!
New kids, you have disobeyed the Grand Wizard.
Where is he?
And by the laws of Zaron.
Oh!
He was right behind me this entire time!
Bro, this is so hard.
So, if he's that difficult, how difficult is Mr. Hankey?
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
I'm just gonna use chain lightning.
This is not good.
Where are you?
What?
Again?
Where did he go?
Which one is he?
Which one's the real Cartman?
That's not the real Cartman.
Oh, no.
He's the one that's running!
He's the fat ass!
Get over here, fat ass!
No, he's not the one running.
Oh my god, I can't figure it out!
Where are you, kid?
We killed so many of them!
Where are they?
That's the last one!
It has to be him!
It's him!
Meteor star!
Okay.
I have a barrier, too.
That's fucking right.
Oh, no.
It's the noodle arms.
Oh!
Barrier!
Okay.
God damn it.
He keeps using barrier!
How can he be so angry?
He's won!
Nice.
Oh, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
We did it, guys.
We defeated Cartman.
We fucking did it.
One more chapter left.
You picked up a bunch of darkness.
High five, lady.
Look at me go.
Oh my god.
Look at that butcher!
Most enemies eliminated.
I knew I was gaming.
I fucking knew I was gaming.
I knew I was carrying chat.
Guys, we're at the final stretch.
We're almost there.
Stage strong, everybody.
Okay.
Everyone have a nice dinner?
Man, I am stuffed.
I think I ate too much.
Haha.
So, Coop.
Back to the game, I guess.
I believe we are about to join forces and battle Mr. Hankey, right?
Fuck you, Cartman.
We're not playing with you anymore.
Yeah, you tried to kill us with dark matter.
You're out of the game.
Well, except you can't kick me out of the game because I'm the Grand Wizard.
So?
Why can't we have a new Grand Wizard?
We know you're not gonna help because you still don't wanna go back to school.
He's right.
You were pretty adamant about not wanting to go back to school.
Well, I've changed my mind.
The truth is none of this is my fault.
I think we all know whose fault it is.
Whose fault is it?
Me?
It's been just a shit show of rules breaking and I got caught up in it just like you.
Like Stan did.
And just like the new kid does all the time.
But we have to find Mr. Hankey and stop this storm.
It's not my fault you guys are all bad at the game.
We should let him play.
He just wants to join us so he can betray us again.
I want to join you because that's the rules.
The losing clan has to join forces with whoever defeated them, right?
That's your rule, Kyle.
And I understand how important rules are because if we don't have rules, then the new kid's just gonna ruin the game like always.
He's got a point there.
What did I do?
We have to take Mr. Hankey down before more people die.
It's not my fault.
I'm just a better gamer than all of you.
I'm gamer of the year.
How is that my fault?
Alright,
let's see if we have...
Oh, we have everything unlocked now.
That seeks enemy and explodes after a short delay?
Wait, that sounds so cool.
That seeks enemies and explodes...
Okay, we don't need heals.
My team will heal for me.
Alright.
That's alright.
My team will heal for me.
Look at that.
Now I have drones.
Alright, we need the dark matter too.
Alright, dark matter time.
No!
They kicked me out!
I have one more please!
I replaced my heals!
They kicked me out!
I don't understand!
What?
They kicked me out!
I was carrying!
Time to set a battle plan.
There has to be somebody.
There has to be somebody on the final game!
There has to be somebody playing the final chapter!
There has to be someone out there!
You're in the cutscene?
Why can't I watch?
What is this?
Why?
Leaving.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
Alright.
I can't believe...
I can't believe nobody is...
Okay, we're just gonna...
Okay, here's the plan.
Chat.
You guys wanna try playing elves sometime?
We're gonna watch the...
We're gonna watch the cutscene from the beginning.
And then...
How come...
How come that fucker...
I'm so mad.
How come that person gets to have...
gets to have four players.
And then I get one real player.
Like...
That's so not fair.
How did they get four people to join them?
And I get one?
Like...
They weren't even good.
This is bullshit.
This is actual bullshit.
This person got four people to join three people.
Four people to join them.
The grand wizard now returned from his temporary but totally understandable madness.
The assault on Mr. Henry Stork is beginning.
They have friends.
I was part of that group!
The war is raging in the human balance of Elk Path.
He's the chosen one.
You're numbered for it.
Hey guys.
One at a time.
Guys.
Hiro, thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you.
Hey guys.
Don't wait up.
There's still 33 seconds.
The choice is yours.
Guys, join me.
Don't wake up everybody.
We're almost there.
Whoa.
Ok, we're all here.
Let's go.
Wait, no we're not.
Guys.
Come on.
You don't want to miss the cutscene.
Guys.
Dragoons.
You don't want to miss the cutscene.
You're still playing this game.
Look.
Look, I'm playing this game to completion so that you guys can see the ending of this game and you don't have to buy it.
I'll say it now, I'm indie.
This game, it's mixed reviews for a reason.
It's only for my love of South Park that I'm willing to play to the end.
I don't buy this game.
Yeah, but he got cancelled.
It's endless winter or we're gonna have to end it ourselves.
You're too late.
This town and Amber...
It's shaky, yeah.
I'm in control now.
All I needed was one of you to use my dark magic and build up its power.
I'd put my money on Stan, but he fucked it up.
And I had to settle for that lame new kid.
Look at the way this little turd dresses and his stupid face.
What?
But I paid 20 extra dollars.
I have the season pass.
I have the season pass though.
Of this amazing game.
He's mocking my cred.
Oh no.
They have the priest.
I have the pre-order privilege.
All right.
Don't you children read the Bible?
Last wave.
Once the hour has come.
Leviticus number two.
That's not a real thing.
Uhhh.
It's in the underbridge tradition.
Are you saying Mr. Hanky the Christmas Poo came out of Jesus' butthole?
Wait, what?
The holiest.
That is the power you're dealing with.
So beware his wrath.
Okay, I wanna be able to summon people.
So, what have we got here, Phelous?
Check this out.
What do you have?
That's that.
And some cards to upgrade our memory.
What does Mr. Hankey have?
Are you serious?
What?
They get...
They get so many fire arrows and ice arrows?
Really?
We're friends?
You're not leeching off of me?
We're actually friends?
Thank you, Lord.
Hell's past hospital.
Guys, see?
I have friends!
I told you guys!
I have real friends, guys!
Guys, look!
I knew they were real!
I knew they were real people!
I knew it!
Chad, I told you.
I told you they're real.
Alright, down we go.
Wee!
Are you friend?
Friend?
There we go.
What the fuck?
He just ran from me!
Guys, what happened to my real people?
My real friends.
Oh my god, there you guys are!
Real friends!
We've been waiting for you, you kids!
There you are, guys!
I knew you were real!
How did... from four...
How did they leave?
How did my real friends left me?
I liked how...
I liked how, like, three of...
Like, two of them left.
Like, my very real friends.
Like, how you're not even actually real!
Oh, fuck this.
I'm sending in the drones.
Alright, guys.
I have an idea.
Guys, we're gonna return to the Koopa Keep.
Now that we saw the cutscene, we're gonna do an epic gamer move.
Watch this.
Now that we know what the cutscene is...
It's time!
It's time for the real gamer move!
Right here!
The pro gamer strap.
Please don't be in any cutscene.
Hey, guys!
Oh, shit!
Are you just starting the new season?
You're gonna do chapter two?
Me too!
Let's go!
Hey, guys!
Wait, did you just finish it?
Wait, no!
They just finished the game!
I think they just finished it!
It's the one...
No, there's no way!
Okay, wait.
I think they actually just finished it.
There's no way!
Because, like, why is it daytime?
Why is it daytime?
I don't understand!
Okay.
This is it.
There has to be somebody on chapter four.
There has to be...
Or, chapter five.
You're out there!
It's you again?!
Bro!
Why is there no one in your lobby?!
There's no one!
You're in the same chapter as me!
There's nobody here!
There's no...
The only player!
I'm sure you did another step!
There's no way!
You have to exist!
Mr. Hayden, you white southwark off the map!
Well, no town, no seas!
Okay.
Maybe if I put normal.
Maybe if I put...
You can't be on normal!
It's you again?!
Do you need a pep talk?
You can do it!
Alright.
Okay, guys.
Guys, we're just testing a theory.
We're just testing a theory.
Chat.
Alright.
There's no way!
If I'm on easy and it's him again, there's no...
No game was found!
I'm so sorry!
He's like...
He's actually the only one!
Oh my god.
It can't be the same person.
Oh my god!
I knew it!
Don't worry!
I got cred!
It's okay, guys!
It's okay!
I got cred!
Oh my god!
Your new friend!
I broke the loop!
I broke the loop chat!
We did it!
We fucking broke the loop!
I can't believe it!
Guys!
We fucking did it!
Oh my god!
We broke the fucking loop!
It's just where I left off to.
It's like...
I would have liked it if they were a little bit ahead.
But like, why would you play on hard and do this to yourself?
You played the other four chapters.
I think what I'm most surprised is the fact that these guys are willing to play hard on the last chapter after going through hard on the other chapters.
That's what I'm most impressed with.
Bye.
Kid Cannon?
Oh no, not the kids.
So Joki, thoughts on this game?
I know why this game is...
There's a reason why this game has mixed reviews.
And...
And it's very reasonable.
It's actually so fucking reasonable.
It is such a reasonable game.
It's such a reasonable choice.
Oh my god.
I'm playing this game right now to the end.
So you guys will not play to the end.
So you guys will know what it's like.
Oh my god.
Where do we go?
Guys, do you guys know where to go?
Do we... oh wait!
Fight your way to the top?
But how do we get to the top?
There goes through...
Oh, we have to go through the hospital.
There's way more shit up there.
You'll want an upgrade.
Okay.
What?
Why do we not defeat?
Alright, you guys go do your thing.
I'm just here to leech.
I wanna...
I wanna know what the fucking ending is.
You guys got this.
I am fighting the real fight right now.
Alright, let's see.
The drone no longer moves but deals 30 damage.
20% more damage?
Wait, how is that better?
Willow Shield is 20% bigger and does 12...
Okay, I feel like that's better.
Alright.
Please don't kick me.
I struggled so hard to get here.
Alright, we need some toilet paper.
Don't kick me, guys.
I worked so hard...
to be here.
Where do we go?
What the wait for...
Did everybody upgrade it?
Enjoy these upgrades, new kid.
You've earned them.
Yeah, that's me.
I'm the new kid.
Where do we go?
Who still hasn't upgraded?
Three!
Hurry the fuck up!
I'm number two!
That means I'm next in succession!
Hey, where's the global warming when we need it, huh?
Wow, what a great audience.
What the fuck, Jimmy?
Oh, there it is.
There's a chest.
What's this?
Oh, bubble shield is bigger.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
I'm stunned.
I'm stunned and I'm bleeding.
Don't worry.
I'm sending out the drones.
The drones are gonna do stuff.
I go down?
I know this is fight your way to the top.
But I'm gonna head down.
Oh, nice.
I got when hit the bubble gains two seconds and make you more pissed off.
Nice.
That's my favorite.
Oh, wait, they're already dead.
Wait, what?
Did I...
Did I go the wrong way?
I did.
Oh, no.
Guys, don't kick me!
I just went the wrong way!
I'm heading to the right way now!
All right, here we go.
Guys!
Do not worry!
I'm gonna go to the right way now!
I'm going to contribute!
I'm here to contribute to the team!
Wait, these guys are actually pretty good.
Oh, my God.
They already killed so many people.
Wait a minute.
This is a team.
This is a team right there.
Where else do we go?
Oh, hey, more chests.
Nice.
We got the chests.
Come on, guys!
Right here!
Follow me!
Dude, I just realized something.
Dark magic is shit.
This whole time, we've been smearing shit on ourselves.
Oh, yeah.
Sad.
Now you know.
I just tried not to think about it.
Because I was so gross.
Now this rush is going back to skew.
Sad.
Now you realize...
Guys!
It's Mr. Hanky!
Oh, my God.
What else would it be?
It's literally Mr. Hanky!
Oh, God.
Okay.
I nearly realized that this is a team game.
Let me go.
Oh!
Okay.
Drone time.
Drone.
Drone to win!
There we go.
I hope my drone is doing something.
I have no idea.
I really hope my drone is actually working.
I almost, like, blamed somebody else.
Okay.
Bubble time.
We gotta go.
Drone!
All right.
Nice.
Got some...
Got some more.
We gotta kill this guy.
Boop!
Get over here.
Get over here, sniper!
We're almost to the top!
One more sixth graders!
We just gotta kill the last sixth...
I got you!
I got the sniper!
Get over here, sniper.
Oh, my God.
I was so fucking spoiled by the legendary.
Nice.
I was really spoiled by the legendary spin.
Please, please, please.
Why is it every time I join somebody else's session...
Everyone in South Park will do whatever they tell them.
Just for a hint of my sweet Christmas magic.
Jimmy!
Now, this is what I call a climax.
Ready for your last upgrade?
Oh, my God.
The last upgrade.
I'm so ready.
Please.
All right.
Your health total is said about 10% less stamina.
Okay.
We need more bubbles.
That's pretty good.
The last one.
Try not to die.
That would be embarrassing.
Guys, we're gonna make it.
Crazy weather we had.
We fucking survived.
The last one.
We're gonna make it.
Oh, my God.
The last upgrade.
We're gonna make it, everybody.
We're so close to the finish line.
Drone.
Please explode.
Okay, guys.
I think I have a feeling that the drone is not that strong.
I realized that possibly the drone was not as strong as I thought it was.
It's making me a little sad that I got the drone.
The drone is a little weak.
Yeah.
The drone kind of sucks, guys.
Why did nobody stop me from getting a drone?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Why did nobody...
That's all the damage it does?
That's actually all the damage it does on the drone.
That's why the one I chose to put the drone on was the one that was the strongest.
I thought you had more damage.
If it was the drone, I would've put the drone on.
I wish my dark matter inside of was you.
All right.
Let's go.
We're almost there.
Team, we're almost at the finish line.
We can't get a refund, because we've committed...
We're committed to seeing the end.
Team, this is it.
The end is so near.
We've invested four hours of the rest of our lives.
Please, where the fuck is the drone?
Where is the other guy?
Where is he?
Did he fall down?
Wait, that's pretty smart Cartman.
Wait, no.
What are you spitting facts?
I already put so much dark matter inside me.
Who's gonna do that?
Guys,
he absorbed four dark matters.
You guys should have listened to me.
What?
You know it's time for all of you to stop.
I wasn't the one that fucked you guys.
It was the other new kids.
I wasn't that strong.
Use your bullshit.
Can't believe it.
Cartman was finally right.
He's right one of ten times.
This is how we leave their offerings for the Great One.
Dark Christmas is upon us.
And he has taken his final form.
The fuck are you talking about final form?
Yeah, what the fuck are you talking about?
Shiza Halu.
What?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, is that the final form that I spoiled myself with because I was trying to like cheese this?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
The part where they're like in the cutscene.
You can't fucking watch it with them.
There's only one way to deal with a bunch of shit.
Toilet paper.
Yeah, toilet paper.
There's a ton of it here.
Great.
We can use those cannons to shoot.
Come on, let's go.
Yankee's true form.
It's okay.
We have to use the toilet paper?
Oh my god, they're babies.
Oh shit.
The cannons won't fire without TP.
Find a pack and bring it there.
I'm trying.
Oh, where the fuck?
I got him.
Oh, there's too many.
I got it.
All right.
Okay.
I'm gonna submit an army.
That's lasers.
That wasn't an army.
That was lasers.
Okay, I'm helping.
Guys, drone.
All right, I'm gonna grab you guys the toilet paper.
You guys do all the other work.
Don't worry.
I'll help you guys get the toilet paper.
Oh, please.
I'm like bait.
I'm the bait.
Don't worry.
There you go.
Grab it.
Oh, god.
Guys, I think I need heals.
Guys.
I think I need heals, guys.
I might have messed up.
I might have messed up and thought I did not need heals.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I need red soon.
Guys, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I believe in you guys.
I'm gonna stay here next to the heals.
Oh, no.
He's gonna fucking hidey-ho me.
Okay.
Get over here.
I got him.
Toilet paper.
I can jump with the toilet paper, too.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Here I go.
I'm gonna be helpful for once in my life.
I'm not gonna leech off.
I'm gonna be helpful.
Here I go.
Alright.
We did it.
Someone help the wizard.
The red wizard.
Someone help him.
Oh, no.
I got the barrier.
He has the toilet paper.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna get the grab.
Oh!
Hey, guys.
I'm also very important.
Hey, everybody.
Hey, guys.
Psych.
Here we go.
Nice.
No!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, there he is.
No.
Okay.
We gotta wait.
Where is he?
Oh, no.
He's gonna be...
Where is he?
Come on.
I'm holding it.
No!
He hasn't hurt me.
He has to show up here.
It's alright.
No, it's not okay.
They damaged it.
He's literally holding it in.
Dodge.
Oh, she got the toilet paper.
Alright.
Where's the other toilet paper?
Where is it?
Why is there a toilet paper up there?
Who's gonna be able to grab it?
What is he looking at?
What is this?
Oh, I got slow-motor some shit.
Oh, god.
Please.
Grab.
Take me to the other.
Please.
I just wanna touch this toilet paper.
Yes!
No!
Guys, please.
I'm not...
I'm not a detriment to this team.
I just need you all to know that.
I just need you all to know.
That I am trying my best right now.
I am trying my best here.
I'm not even trying.
I'm not trying to be a bad person.
Oh, no.
My team is so smart.
I'm like the distraction.
I'm bait.
I'm just...
What the fuck happened to me?
What the fuck?
I got gang-banged by a bunch of poop.
Like, what the fuck?
Hey, guys.
An important member here.
Number two.
It's okay.
I'm just bait.
Here we go.
We're fine.
We did it!
Oh my god!
I existed.
I...
Guys, we did it.
Oh my god.
What a team.
What a fucking team.
Oh.
What a team, chat.
What a beautiful team.
You picked up a bunch of dirt matter.
How's that, lady?
They're so good.
We're all so good, chat.
We're all...
We did it.
They wouldn't have made it there without me.
The storm has lifted.
The snow is melting.
And toilet paper is once again just for the best.
We're wiping your butt.
Things are going back to normal in South Park.
And we're all gonna be alright.
All of us except for the thousands who tragically lost their lives.
That's alright.
Back to you, Tom.
I've just been told that Tom has also tragically lost his life.
No, not Tom!
Back to you, Kelly.
Who's gonna report the news?
What about me?
We all have to go.
You know, not that long ago I prayed to God.
And all I asked was to not get totally fucked.
School isn't that bad, dude.
No, no, it's okay.
I'm pretty used to getting fucked now.
It's just sort of par for the course when you have faith in a higher power.
Who the fuck is that?
That can't be Hanky.
We killed him.
Jesus!
Oh my God!
My children, I am very disappointed in all of you.
What?
All of us?
Yeah, what did we do?
Every Christmas, Mr. Hanky brought you happiness and joy.
And yet, when he got canceled for his Twitter posts, you would not forgive him.
You would not forgive him.
No, that was everyone else in town.
We didn't care.
And yet, did you stand by Mr. Hanky's side when everyone turned on him?
Everyone turned on him.
Who the fuck requested the skip?
But the only mistake that is true is not to forgive.
It is up to you to make more mistakes.
Oh, come on.
Mr. Hanky?
Whose toilet does he live in?
We should have had your back.
Yeah, we should have had each other's backs.
All this talking, all this talking about the rules, what's wrong and right.
Yeah, if anyone's been a piece of shit, it's been us.
You guys don't mean it.
Yeah, yeah, we mean it.
Really.
We messed up too, Mr. Hanky.
Everybody does.
This like feels good orchestra music.
We're sure, Mr. Hanky.
We love you.
Oh my god.
Well, howdy-how!
Thank you, boys!
This is the best day of my life!
Now we just gotta figure out how to get the rest of the town to forgive you.
I don't care what the town thinks of me.
So long as I have you kids.
Oh, great!
Now we can all be friends again.
And maybe sometimes, just sometimes, you can make a blizzard again.
So we can have another snow day.
Maybe like right now?
Could you, Mr. Hanky?
Could we just have like one more snow day?
One more snow day so we can have more Dungeons & Dragons!
And it's snowing again!
Yay!
Time to kill another thousand people!
One more time!
Ooh, you're loaded with dark matter!
We did it!
I was gonna ask, is there an after credits scene?
But I don't think there's enough people to know if there's an after credits scene.
I can't tell.
I don't think there's enough people to fucking figure this out.
What about the new kid?
Did we just forgot about the new kid?
Lobster, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
What a fucking journey.
Alright, let's go.
Okay.
I love Trey Parker and Matt Stone and like, I love like the stuff they do.
I even went to the Book of Mormon musical with the original cast and got like, I bought like VIP seats like not VIP, sorry, like some of the best seats for Book of Mormon because it was like one of the musicals I've always wanted to watch.
And I was like in New York at the time for like a conference like an academic conference so I was lucky enough to see the Book of Mormon with with the original cast you know, before they all went become stars in their own right.
And like, I love the Book of Mormon and I love like all the stuff they do.
I love like when they were the guy, one of them, when they did the voice acting for one of the Despicable Me movies that was pretty fucking funny.
But like, holy fuck.
This game.
This game was a fucking chore to play.
I took a risk and a gamble to play this game on launch.
Because I was like okay, I had a feeling it won't be like the perfect game because it's like this weird this is a new area they're gonna play they're gonna, like there's a new area they're gonna play.
And I wanted to explore.
But oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
This game.
I think it just needed something.
It felt really repetitive.
The longer the longer you play it the, it got like more and more repetitive.
So like, it just needed something more.
It just, it really needed something more.
It felt like really fucking repetitive.
Oh my god.
But we did it.
Guys.
We fucking did it.
I can't believe zero, when I tried to queue up for easy, zero game, zero players were playing.
That's that was actually crazy.
There was nobody playing a game on easy.
And one guy on normal.
Oh, we cleared it.
We fucking did it.
I wanted to go all the way to the end.
I wanted to play all the way to the end.
But oh my god.
Oh my god.
What a journey that was.
I'm just happy we made it to the end chat.
I'm so happy we made it.
GG's everybody.
GG's.
I played this game so you guys don't have to.
I had to I wanted to go all the way to the end so you guys don't have to.
I know it might not have been like the most engaging stream to watch, but thank you for sticking it through with me.
Thank you.
When I got to okay at first I was like okay I'm gonna play two chapters.
I'm just gonna play two chapters and then I'm gonna call it there and then never touch the game again.
But then I played two chapters and then the thing is we were past the two hour mark after the two chapters.
So then I was like alright fuck it.
There's nothing I can do.
I might as well play it to the end and get my money's worth cause I pre-ordered the deluxe version.
I was like I I got through the end I was like oh my god.
I might as well.
I pre-ordered it.
Got the deluxe version.
You know okay Okay the funniest thing the funniest thing was that I saw that um what was his name?
I saw was it Nogla?
Like I saw like uh fuck was it Nogla that had like early access to this game?
And I was like okay I'm gonna watch this a little bit so I know.
Not Nogla.
Uh fuck what's his name?
Oh yeah no like Nogla and like his friends.
Um who was the other guy that also got like Vanoss and everybody.
Uh god what was like I'm trying to remember.
Oh yeah.
Delirious yeah.
Uh Terrorizer Delirious and Nogla they got like sponsored by they got they got sponsored by this game.
And I was watching it a little bit because I was like oh early access and then I was like okay cause I was like oh hey they're streaming early access like the early release copy of the fucking game.
And then I was watching it.
I was I watched five minutes and then they were like this is the best game we ever played.
they were like they were like oh my god this is so fun.
I oh my god guys this is so fucking fun this is one of the best multiplayer games I've played.
I was like bruh.
They were like they were like oh my god this is so fucking fun guys.
And I was like Oh my god, isn't it actually that fun?
No, they were.
They were sponsored.
So like it's understandable.
But like I... bro, I like I was like I believed it a little bit.
I was like, okay, because I was like, oh man.
I was hesitant.
I don't... that was... I watched the early copy and that's why I bought the deluxe version.
I bought the deluxe... I pre-ordered the deluxe version because I was like, oh my god.
Maybe it's not that bad because I was worried.
I was like, oh man, I'm worried.
I fell for it.
I actually fell for it because they actually sounded really exciting.
Excited.
They actually sounded so excited.
I fucking fell for it.
I fucking... I fucking fell for the sponsor.
I was like...
Oh my god, they sound like they're actually having so much fun.
So... so... because that was what pushed me to pre-ordering the deluxe version over like the normal copy.
Like I was like, do I get the deluxe copy or do I... because I was like, okay, if I get the normal copy, I'll just do like... I'll just like play the first two chapters and then call it because I have feeling.
I was like, oh, it doesn't really look that fun as fun as like the other games, the older games.
And then... and then like...
And then I watched their sponsored stream.
I watched five...
Five minutes of their sponsored stream.
And that was the moment where they were like, oh my god, this game is so fun.
And then I was like, oh my god, maybe it is so fun.
So then I was like, alright, I'm going...
I...
I'm... I am going to risk it.
I'm gonna risk it.
I fell for it.
What you want to believe.
The thing is, when the creators...
When the creators actually like take control, like take creative control, they can't...
They can make really, really, really good things.
Like... like... like...
Uh... the creators of South Park, when they have majority of the creative control, they're really good at making really good games or really good shows or really good like musicals and stuff like that.
But I don't know what happened to this game.
I don't know what happened to this game.
Like, they had creative control.
So like, what the fuck happened?
Like... what?
Yeah.
Yeah, Tray and Matt.
I was so surprised.
Because usually they do really well.
Like the... the...
The Stick of Truth and like the Fractured But Whole.
Those are really good...
I mean, I haven't played Fractured But Whole, but I heard it was a really good game too.
Uh...
They were really good.
And then... like the musical stuff.
That was really good.
What the fuck happened here?
What... what happened?
I'm so sad!
It was made by a different studio?
Maybe.
I think it's 3D.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Different dev team?
I guess.
Yeah.
Thank you.
But like, I don't know.
I trusted... I trusted... I trusted the creators.
Because like usually when they're head of the creative team.
Um... they work really hard in trying to make a good game.
So I was... I was just surprised that...
It was just mid.
It was so mid.
It was...
It's not like super shitty.
It was just really mid.
It was incredibly mid.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Uh...
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm pretty tired.
That game really took a lot out of me.
So... but I hope you guys still enjoyed your time with me today.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.